autocad is a popular computer-aided
design software used to design and model
in 2d and 3d
in this university course you will learn
the basics of autocad
hello hello and welcome to ada
a course the first course that we teach
for the first year students in lth in
linden university
um and this course is all about
showing you the basics of autocad and
getting you into cat drawing
so it's going to be all about
two-dimensional drawing rather than
three-dimensional modeling at first
but uh even with that there's a lot of
things to learn and a lot of things to
understand so we'll be using autocad
exactly for that right
once you
actually opened up autocad you will
be greeted with this welcome screen
right the start screen and the start
screen is going to have the recent
documents uh row or whatever
column i guess and it's going to have
the basic buttons get started open files
and blah blah so recent documents is
basically if if you're all if you have
already worked on something
that file is going to pop up here just
for convenience if you haven't it's
going to be empty right
so instead you just press the star
drawing and that's exactly what we're
going to do actually let me see
okay
uh so we're going to click on start
drawing
like that
okay so this is what we have here uh
this this kind of user interface and you
can't really see the top top of the row
but
there's basically nothing there that's
super important it's just a bunch of
different icons
if you click on the large
icon in the top left corner
the large a button
you will see all of the same
tools that are available for you create
a new file open an existing one save
files export files publish files or
print files i guess
right so printing is oh actually
i'll i'll talk about it once we get
there right
um but the basic menu is is here right
it's located underneath that large a
button
underneath it you have what's called the
ribbon menu
and this is the ribbon menu has a bunch
of tabs
so it's like categories
with the tools that you can use but
honestly
the faster you learn the commands for
the tools rather than the
clicking on the icons of the tools the
better it is right because
uh it just speeds up your drawing
process quite a bit once you actually
remember the shortcuts or the commands
for the tools so honestly i almost never
use the
the icons anymore i just type in the
the commands and
anyone that you ask who is using how to
get this the same
nevertheless uh we will be kind of
clicking on these and and looking where
they are
but also we will be memorizing the
shortcuts for them as well
there is this
home tab so the home type is going to be
99 of the time we are going to be
spending in the home tab
then we have the insert tab
i will from time to time we will go in
here and use one or two tools from here
there's not much here then we have the
annotate tab where
yeah we will be spending good time here
as well
every other tab is
we ignored it it's it doesn't exist to
us we don't care
right so it's only these three tabs
uh by now you might be wondering well
that that you probably have more stuff
here right more floating windows here
um
that might happen because you either
have autocad
architecture
rather than just regular autocad or
maybe
these days autocad just ships with
multiple open panels actually can i show
you
let's see if i close that
no
start drawing
it doesn't open up any panels here but
if you have any panels opened up that
are just floating on the screen close
them click the x buttons and then just
close them you don't need to see them
right just click clean up the screen
one more thing is right now what you see
here on the screen is me logged into a
school's computer right so on the
school's computers for instance
we are running autocad architecture 2019
and it has the home tab has these three
dimensional tools of wall door and so on
and also it does have the two
dimensional
tools
we will not be using three-dimensional
tools in this course at all because
first of all autocad is not that great
for three-dimensional modeling compared
to competitors
second of all it's better to first learn
how to draw and then learn how to model
rather than kind of trying to learn
everything all at once it's much a
easier learning curve that way
um so we will be only using 2d drawings
there's one more thing that i want to
check and i will be checking i will
check if there's a possibility on how to
hide this
and that
the way you hide this is if you use a
different
profile a different viewing template and
i'll i'll just try let me close this
let me try to open it again
but this time around
what if we use
no template metric
now it still opens up okay fair enough
anyway so those of you who have this
build tab here just ignore it we will
not be using it we will be using this
and i'll be kind of switching back and
forth between the two versions this
version and the version that i have
this version right here just so that
everyone sees you know where different
tools are located
one more thing
is the course website if we go to the
course website
it does have
autocad basic commands pdf right here
which i will open
and actually i'll be using it too and
this is not a lot of
tools
but i will be using it to go through
these tools and kind of explain you what
what they do before we actually begin
well most of them
before we begin actually going deep into
drawing a building i will be showing how
to do that as well but first let's just
kind of look at the tools
um
so have that
opened as well just ready for you
right so let's jump into autocad uh back
into autocad and here there's this grid
that you see here is your main viewport
right
and it's basically a two-dimensional
view you can make it three-dimensional
with this box here uh by clicking on the
on the side of the box and now it's it's
a three-dimensional space
three-dimensional grid but you don't
wanna do that so
what you do is you just click on the top
of the box like so and it's going to
rotate back to two dimensions we are
going to draw it in everything in two
dimensions flat
right
if your top the name top
is not
oriented properly
let's see if it's like so if it's
rotated like so just use these arrows to
kind of rotate it back to to normal so
this is what you want to see north
south east west top right
okay
the way you
move inside of this view
is there's no
there's no right click and holding
right instead
if you click and hold the
scroll map or scroll wheel
of the mouse
you can pan the view
right
like that
if you scroll the wheel of course you
zoom out zoom in zoom out zoom in
right into the view
and and that's it that's all you need
honestly you know you just need to be
able to pan the view and zoom in to to
the cursor by the way it always zooms
into where you have your your cursor
that's important
selecting objects is that is done
through
by by clicking and dragging the mouse
and by now you will notice that if you
click and drag the mouse
um
with the left mouse button it kind of
does this
so this is what's called like a smart
selection i absolutely hate it i or
lasso tool lasso selection tool method i
absolutely hate it i think it's
obnoxious
so the first thing that we will actually
do is we will get rid of it right so
let's get rid of that i just want it to
be like a rectangular marking but it
doesn't let me
um to get rid of it
here in the bottom you have the command
line this is where you write all of the
commands right
um
and i can just write options
and hit enter
so i wrote options i hit enter and it
opens up options for me
options
um and then in the options options tab
or options menu i can go to
actually let's take a look at this re
real quick just so that you know what's
going on
files this is basically where all of the
supporting files are located you don't
care about this display is you can
change the color theme between dark and
light
whatever crosshair size
let me show you i'll increase the
crosshair size to 100 hit apply hit ok
and now my
my crosshair looks like this this is
quite useful when you want to
or my mouse this is quite useful when
you want to align
um
see if stuff is aligned properly and i
honestly
i have been using it for quite a while
it's quite convenient but at the same
time
sometimes it gets in the way right i'll
type in options again and
make it smaller
was it five i think it was five i don't
remember
are you five yeah it was five okay
so i'll i change it back to five
everything else here is just basically
how are things shown
um i wouldn't suggest you going deep
into this and changing stuff up
um definitely not now later once you're
used to the program
opening and saving it's basically going
to ask you what what kind of format do
you want to always save the file in and
that's don't argue with the program it
knows what it's doing so don't don't
mess around here
plot and publish as well is it's
basically where will you
export out the pdfs
don't argue with the program
system
[Music]
let's ignore it user preferences let's
definitely ignore it
or wait
yes
drafting and 3d modeling
um
[Music]
i'm just sorry i'm just really quickly
going through this and seeing if there's
anything worth mentioning
not really
defaults are absolutely fine 3d modeling
we're not going to do any 3d modeling so
we don't care and then selection so this
is the big big boy where
the culprit behind our lasso tool
selection right
so it's here allow press and drag for
lasso this line right here in this tick
mark right here
is is the the culprit so i'll untick it
and i'll just hit apply
and hit ok
and now it's fine
you'll notice that the color is
different
depending if i'm going from bottom up or
from top to bottom but it's uh
it's
i i will talk about that later
what matters is that it's a rectangle
right and not that ugly lasso
okay so that's the first thing let me
double check if in the other version in
in this uh
our autocad architecture version if it's
the same i'll just go to options
selection
yeah it's the same allow press and drag
for lasso and now it works okay
let's jump back here so that's that um
below you have a model space layout
space and so on we will be talking about
those uh during the last tutorial uh not
right now and then you have a bunch of
uh a bunch of stuff here
uh that is not enough stuff i want to
see more oh yeah okay that's enough
stuff that's good we will talk about
those as well later
for now
let's actually start start looking into
the tools and start drawing right that's
the fun part
um
the question is
what's what are the units the
measurements in which we draw is it
centimeters is it millimeters is it
inches is it horses per second you know
what kind of
dimensions are we talking about
i need to
actually make sure that i'm drawing for
instance in millimeters i'm used to
drawing in millimeters
so what i'll do is i will type
a command called units
units
enter
[Music]
and here i will see that indeed i am
drawing in millimeters and this is my
precision of drawing
0.0000 millimeters right so it's pretty
damn precise
um and degrees are or sorry the angle is
in degrees not in radians that's great
the precision is only
full numbers of degrees
which
i have a problem with
i do want the precision to be slightly
larger for four degrees at least you
know one number after the comma so i'll
just choose 0.0
and then lighting we don't care we don't
care about
once i've made sure that it's
millimeters and degrees i'll just hit ok
and now we know that we are drawing in
millimeters
okay
now it's time to draw the easiest thing
to draw is a line right so the line tool
is located here
well the one that says line
and
if you don't see it then you might have
this version where yeah it's here right
or
the shortcut for the line tool is
l
enter
l is short for line
once you
hit l enter or you click on this icon
here
you will
start reading you will need to read what
it's asking of you
in the command line so the way autocad
communicates with you
about what it wants from you to actually
be able to draw stuff
is through the command line
so here it's asking line specify first
point
sure i need to click somewhere right so
i'll just click
ok
then command line immediately switches
to another question specify next point
right uh sure
i'll click again
and then
autocad keeps asking me to specify next
point uh okay
next point okay so you can see that i
can keep doing this this for for for a
while right just keep drawing the
the lines
which is not you know at some point i
want to stop so the way you stop is you
just hit enter
right to finish the tool
to finish the command
you hit enter and you have a bunch of
lines so now if i hover my mouse over
them i can see that only segments like
these straight line segments get
highlighted and i can kind of select
them
right select this one
select that one
like that one for instance so i can
click on them to select
that's cool
uh how do i unselect well i hit escape
escape unselects them right
what if i want to select
many of them
without actually
you know kind of clicking on each
individual line segment well i can
drag
this rectangle here around the ones that
i'm going to select
release
and these get selected right
um which actually and then escape to and
select of course uh which actually um
yeah let's do a small small bit a small
tutorial about selection here uh because
we already have some geometry that's
available for us so i'm going to
as i mentioned before there are two ways
of how to select the
the blue rectangle
which happens when you drag from left to
right
and the green rectangle which happens
when you drag from right to left
right
so the blue rectangle only selects
things that are completely inside
of that
rectangle
right so for instance let's let's look
at this line right here
this this line right here right if i
drag the blue rectangle
and it's crossing that line
and i release
that line doesn't get selected because
it's not fully inside it wasn't fully
inside of that blue rectangle
if
i
drag a green rectangle
and it's crossing the line in the same
way
it is going to to be selected right
that's because the blue line only
selects things that are completely or
blue rectangle a
blue selection rectangle only selects
things that are completely inside of it
while the green selection rectangle
selects things that are inside of it and
things that it's
hitting things that it's crossing right
so again the blue rectangle selection
looks like that while the green
rectangle selection looks
like that because it's hitting this line
hitting this line hitting this line and
hitting this line right
so that's that
um
right so so now we have something drawn
cool
uh let's select all of it
and hit delete
you know that's how you get rid of stuff
you just hit the delete button
mac users backspace probably i don't
remember you can type in delete i think
so yes erase sorry you can type in erase
command and it's going to erase it
um
let me just see here l
same same thing
good i'm just double checking if
yeah
yeah okay double checking if there are
no kind of discrepancies between the two
versions that's good for now
um so that's our
line tool which is right here that's the
first tool let me talk more about it
um just so that you you get
a better idea of how things are drawn
so that line tool again l enter for line
l enter um
i i will specify the first point by just
clicking but then the second point
let's say i want it
at this
angle whatever angle right but i want it
to be
um
[Music]
let's see two meters long right
2 000 millimeters
so what i do is before i
click again you know to
to finish the tool
or to finish the line before i click
again i can type in the desired length
two thousand
you know two meters enter
and now it becomes exactly two meters
long in that direction
right
which is quite useful
what if
i want to draw
this line segment
completely horizontal
right or completely vertical doesn't
matter
then the tool that does that is called
orthographic snapping
and the shortcut for it is f8
f8 in the top of your keyboards f8
or
a button that does that
is located right here and in the bottom
of the screen
ortho mode and you can see in the
brackets it says f8 as well
if ortho mode is turned on
if i click on it or if i hit f8 right
so with f8 i can turn it on or off right
if i hit a fit or turn it on and i draw
try to draw the line and this time let
me just use the tool uh the icon here
and i draw the line you can see that
it's locked to either a horizontal or
vertical position
right which is quite useful for instance
i want to say
uh 5000 millimeters
or not
let's do 2 000 5000 was way too long two
thousand millimeters five hundred
millimeters
uh
a thousand millimeters
500 more
300 millimeters
uh 750
i don't know how long this is probably
around
700 millimeters yes and then close it
off and hit enter
right i can have pretty precise
dimensions
when when i have ortho on
so that's quite useful
i will show you later a few more
tips and tricks in terms of the angles
and snapping to different angles but
also
turning ortho on and off is one of the
smoothest workflows let's see or or most
useful workflows let me get rid of this
so that's how you how you work with
lines and then horizontal and vertical
snapping of of lines let me turn off
ortho for now so i either click here on
this icon or just hit f8 and i can see
that that icon is turned off now
um i can
also i need to check
here
if that's the same thing
yes you do have ortho mode here
that's good
um okay
coming back here
so that's line right um
next up is polyline i believe
yes next step is power line so line
line tool is the most simplistic tool
and it all it can do is just straight
line segments that are all so to say
exploded they are
separated line segments right
polyline tool on the other hand
is
it it can contain much more information
inside of it
what i mean by that is first of all
let's learn the shortcut for it the
shortcut is pl
enter or clicking the icon of course but
pl enter
gives you the polyline tool
and with
orthographic snapping turned off i will
just draw quickly draw a polar line
without any dimensions whatsoever
i'll just draw it
whatever
i have no idea what i'm drawing but it
is what it is yeah let's see something
like that and oops
and hit enter
to finish the the tool
um
so now this is a polyline rather than
the line tool
if i click
on this you can see that everything gets
selected
this is a type of geometry that consists
of multiple lines and all of them are
joined into a chain of lines
it's super convenient for selection
purposes it's super convenient to work
with
and it doesn't really have any any
drawbacks
almost all of the lines that i draw
during the design process
and the technical process later on
are polar lines not lines
keep that in mind
um right so we have our our polyline
can you
make
apollo line
into multiple lines right can can you
explode the polyline into multiple lines
yes you can of course
you can just select it
oh by the way if i use the blue
selection rectangle it will not select
unless i have the whole poly line inside
of my blue selection rectangle while
with the green one i can just kind of
slightly hit it and it will select the
whole thing quite useful
um so right we have a polyline how to
how do we make it into multiple lines
how do we explode it well we use the
explode tool
when we have it selected we just type in
explode
i think it's ex
el
explode
enter
and it just explodes
right so now all of these are separate
line segments and then you go oh no i
didn't want to explode it uh what do i
do now well
if you just did it
really recently you can just do ctrl z
you know undo and it's going to undo
your tool right ctrl z control
yeah control z this is undo ctrl y i
believe is redo
um
yeah
or
if you don't want to do ctrl z or
rather if you already have a bunch of
exploded lines and you want to join them
up well you just select all of them
and type in join
and hit enter
and it just joins all of them up into
one poll line back into one poll line so
there is explode
and there is join right quite useful
okay there are more things about the
polyline that i kind of want to show you
[Music]
let me just think
if it's if it's the time if it's the
time to show you those uh those things
well maybe uh sure let's start pretty
pretty hardcore pl enter
so polyline
i'll start drawing
and i'll just create the first line
segment
and what if i don't want this to be a
straight line what if i want this to be
a curve an arc
right
i can't do that do it with a polyline
tool
here in the bottom you can see that it
does have much more
settings
to choose from
rather than just having give me the next
point because it says specify next point
or
is it an arc is it closed would you like
to close it is it half wave and so on so
there are a lot of hidden settings in
these tools
that you will kind of you will learn
them once you need them
let's say it like that right once you
have a problem to solve then you will
learn that different tools have
different like small settings that you
can tweak to solve that problem
we definitely don't have time to go
through all of the settings of all of
the tools and autocad it's a little bit
too big
for that
but the basic one that i want to show
you is the arc right
and you can see that a is highlighted
right so what i'm going to do is i could
just click here but rather i will press
a
type in a as i'm still drawing the
polyline by the way i'll press a hit
enter
and now i'm in what's called an arc mode
right so you can see that all of the
tools have changed
or not the tools the settings have
changed and i have more more even more
settings to work with but for now i'll
just work with this right so i have the
arc tool
and i can mess around with it
quite a bit
say something like that
and now if i want to change it back
to the line tool
i all i need to do is just type in l
and hit enter
and now we're continuing uh we continue
drawing in straight line segments
right
once we're done we just hit enter and
now we have this kind of polyline
uh quite nice quite quite useful which
can also by the way be exploded and
you know
these settings or these these arcs can
be
deleted off and and whatnot
uh
yo
why is my okay my autocad just lagged a
bit but that's fine
so that's polyline and that's all of the
not all of them uh just one hidden
setting inside of polyline i will show
you more uh
later
once once we actually need them
right let's
cross off polyline from our
list and then we have the arc tool and
the circle tool oh yeah i already showed
you
[Music]
i already showed you the advanced pollen
apologies for that for not keeping to
the script
i just wanted to show it to you
okay let's jump to arc and circle tools
um
i will
well they are located here of course
circle arc right and also
um
also here you have the arc
and you have the circle uh but you don't
have the power line here but if you
expand it by clicking this this small uh
triangle here you will see the poll line
pop up here
again i do suggest you using the command
line instead
so we have the arc in the circle
well
let's start with the circle it's easier
so circle is c
enter
you just click on where you
want the circle center to be
and you
kind of type in the radius that you want
let's see 250
right so now we know that the diameter
of the circle is 500 radius 250 and it's
located right here cool
um what else can we do with a circle
let's see c enter
there's like uh there are a few options
here that we can use and i will for
instance without clicking anywhere i
will just select this three point
uh 3p
option
like that
and now i will click three times on the
screen
right
and you can see that those three clicks
that i made describe
the the circle's position and radius
right so that circle is touching those
three points that i that i clicked i can
do it again
uh c enter
three points
click
click
and then if i say that well actually i
want the third one to be right here
it's going to be like a very weird
circle
click the three points again circle is
touching them pretty cool
then we have the arc tool which is
basically i believe it's a yeah a short
for arc hit enter
and it's basically specify start point
of arg
okay
specify second point of arc
okay
specify the end of arc
okay
so we have our arc
done here if i want it to be a little
bit
um
if i want to draw it differently i can
by the way when you hit enter
if you don't have any commands running
and you hit enter it repeats the last
command that you did so now i don't need
to type in a enter i can just hit enter
and it's going to kind of repeat the
the previous command which was arc
um
instead of specifying the start point i
will choose center here
so i'm starting to draw from the center
see from here and then it's going to ask
me to give it the start
and to give it the end
right
i'm basically just drawing part of the
circle well arc is an arc is a part of a
circle
okay so that's that that's the circle
and that's the arc that there's nothing
more honestly to them
um
there's also like rectangle tools and
whatnot uh perhaps i should wait
i will be showing you rectangle tools
later
though there's no
i haven't even
written it down here so sure
let's let's ignore them
um
for now
circle arc
line polyline
is enough to describe okay so these four
tools circle arc line polyline are
enough to describe any kind of geometry
absolutely
like there's no type of geometry
that you couldn't draw out
with these tools
right
so the basics are super simple
and what a rectangle is is basically a
polyline with
like
parallel line segments right
making it a rectangle
i will just really quickly show it to
you and then we'll jump jump into
snapping possibilities
so
rectangle
rectangle
i just like to write erect
but wait
r e
c
r e c is is enough for for rectangle to
start
working as a command
but i i don't know why i have a muscle
memory of typing in r e c t rect
hit enter
uh it's gonna start drawing the
rectangle and it's going to ask me to
give it the first point sure i will just
click
and that's going to ask me to give it
another corner point right
or
or
i can give it the dimensions so i think
dimensions is a much more useful use
case than just giving it two points so i
will choose dimensions
and i'll say specify length for a
rectangle so i will say well my length
should be
again two meters
two thousand millimeters that's the
length
i hit enter and then i specify with
four rectangles so i'll say
let's do a pretty
narrow one so i'll say
10 centimeters 100 millimeters right 100
enter
that's it right
it kinda is asking me for oh right right
right sorry sorry that's not it
once we added the
the
dimensions
now with a
mouse click i need to specify
the alignment of the rectangle
is it going down or is it going up right
down or up down or up i'll say up and
i'll just
click that's it now it's done right and
we have a rectangle which is basically
just a polyline if i grab the polyline
pl i start started working with it with
ortho on which is f8 and i typed in 2
000 enter and i typed in 100 enter
2000
enter
clicked here enter
that's it that's this absolutely like
these two geometries
are absolutely the same
right
so that's that
okay
let's
let's look
into delete that let's look into
object snapping and ways of how you can
snap to
different parts of objects and you know
kind of merge everything together much
more or rather use geometry
as reference for creating more geometry
you'll see what i mean
the second
all right so object snapping
here in the bottom
uh right here
you will see
oh snap tool object snap tool
uh which basically that small arrow
right next to it
will
expand will expand
there we go a menu oh
right
there we go
just fixing it uh we'll expand the menu
or what types of
sub geometries can you snap to so there
are like end points of lines there are
midpoints of lines and so on so i will
i'll start showing you
um
different ways or or yeah different ways
of how you can snap your geometry
so for now
let us
untick
all of the snaps
all together
right
so nothing is marked
click anywhere on the screen and let's
draw
a line right just a line
line
from here
and i will be drawing it straight
like vertical
i'll just give it
so if you can't just f8 or ortho snap
turn it on and then you will be able to
uh and i'll just give it 2 000
millimeters
hit enter
enter again
right
now it's drawn
and
honestly i just want to move it away
from the zero zero zero coordinate so
this guy right here is my zero zero zero
so i will just select it
m enter empty move
i'll just move it away
so when i try to move it with
orthographic snap
uh maybe i need to do this slower sorry
sorry i'm speeding i will select it
m
enter m short for move enter i will
click anywhere on the screen
doesn't matter where i click
and then as i kind of move my mouse you
can see that you know it's it's being
moved
in relation to my mouse cursor
but since i have orthographic snapping
turned on it can only move horizontally
or vertically right i'll hit f8 or
turn off or to snap here
and now i can move it anywhere on on the
screen so i'll just move it somewhere
here it doesn't matter away from the
zero zero zero
i'll zoom into it
right so that's my my line tool
now since we have all of the object
snapping turned off if i want to create
let's say a circle
or
yeah let's say a circle around
this endpoint i can't because
well i can't snap to it
and i can get pretty close but the
closer i zoom in
uh
i keep seeing that there's an error in
my uh it's going to be an error in my uh
in the center point where where i place
it right so this is not to work instead
let me hit escape to close that tool
instead i am going to
tick mark
the end point snapping here
that's enabled now
and now if i choose my circle
circle tool
i can click on it
oh
actually when i choose my circle tool
and i hover my mouse next to the end
point you can see that there's this
green icon appearing that green icon
basically tells me that i am going to
snap and i'm going to start drawing from
this point right from this end point and
it even says end point right
that means if i now click
the center point of this circle is right
at the end of that line so i can make it
larger
um yeah let's say 300 millimeters
and hit enter
so now i have my line tool or or my
circle directly centered around the
endpoint of the line
i can do this again
c enter from here
300 enter
right i have my two circles
uh that's the first thing that you can
snap to another thing that you can snap
to
is the midpoint right so let me enable
that
enable midpoint
again i'll get the circle
i'll start drawing the circle or rather
i'll hover my mouse over the where i
imagine the midpoint of the line is
going to be which is right here
i'll click
and start drawing
right
so you can see that it even gives me the
mark
let me do that again
as as i'm hovering it even gives me the
triangular mark here and says midpoint
right i'll draw drag draw it out and
i'll say 500
for the radius right
this circle is located directly in the
middle of this line
a circle
at least to my knowledge
yes
the circle doesn't have neither a start
or endpoint or it doesn't have a
midpoint as well because it's infinite
in
in its length right
so you can't snap to a circle
in in this way
said that there is the center
snapping
that we can do right
center snapping for a circle so what i'm
going to do is i will create one more
circle
somewhere close by somewhere i don't
know maybe here
i'll create one more circle and i'll
just give it 500 millimeters again
right
and i will enable
center snapping here
i'll draw
let's just draw another circle inside of
the circle right
so i'll choose a circle tool again
and now as i
as i hover my mouse on the edge of the
circle you can see that green uh circle
appearing or green markup appearing
right in the middle
right if i click
my next circle is going to be drawn in
the middle of the previous one
right so i can give it 300
millimeters for instance and i can keep
doing that right i can keep hitting
enter
you repeat the last command i can keep
drawing
drawing it out
like so
okay
that's one thing
next up we have geometric sender so
geometric center is different from a
center point in the sense that
um
i believe if you have a rectangle let me
just check
i don't want to lie
okay if you have a
if you just use the center snapping
right
it doesn't have
um
it only works on arcs
and it only works on circles it doesn't
work on closed shapes
so if you have some sort of a closed
shape such as a
rectangle
then geometric snapping is going to
be the way to go right so i'll turn on
geometric center
or geometric center snapping sorry it's
going to be the way to go i'll turn on
geometric center
and as i am moving along this this this
rectangle you can see that the middle
while it gives me that
snowflake thingy
it doesn't give me a green
green icon meaning that i can't snap to
it but
if now i hover my mouse close to that
snowflake
now i'm able
now i'm able to snap
right i'll repeat it again hovering my
mouse
finding that
until i see that that snowflake appear
clicking on it and dragging out
like that
okay
so that's done um
so that's geometric center uh there's
more stuff that you can do for instance
if you have a polyline uh which makes a
weird form
something like that
and as long as that polyline is closed
meaning
it needs to end where it started
click
and then hit enter
right it's it's a closed polyline right
now
and i grab a circle
it will show me where the geometric
centroid is right
and i can't snap to it but it's of
course going to be funky
it is accurate mathematically it is an
accurate geometric centroid of this
particular shape but it might be
counterintuitive for you visually right
seeing it there
the way it's calculated is basically
it's an average of all of the corners
the average coordinate of all of the
corners of this polyline just for for
the geeks out there who want to know how
it works
okay
so that's that um then we have node
snapping which
i don't care
never use it it's basically if you have
points in in your
in your drawing we will not be using
points so
we don't care
i will not be even showing you this
quadrant snapping though is quite useful
uh if i select it
i tick mark that
now every circle
that i drew
has a quadrant right it has a quadrant
here here here and here
i can actually show them by choosing a
circle or rather on this one
and i can see that now i can snap to
this
spot here
i can snap to this spot here
this spot here
and this spot here
right
so i can i can snap to four points on
each of the circles
quite useful in in some cases
right
and you can kind of go even deeper and
then kind of keep keep snapping to those
to those
quadrants to create pretty
pretty intense graphics
um right
so that's quadrant snapping
next up
we have intersection
so a very simple
simple explanation would be if i have a
line tool
you know i just draw a line here and i
draw another one here
right
let me actually draw another
one come on i'll enter
another one right here
if i want to snap to that particular
point i can
by using the intersection snap right so
it kind of finds all of the places where
two geometries intersect right
so i can draw a circle around that
intersection now
quite useful
in this case you might kind of be using
it for
for this
for instance
right and then even smaller
right
so so that's in intersections it just
finds intersections between any kind of
two two two geometries
any type of two geometries
uh right
so that's in intersection snapping next
next next there's extension snapping um
later not now
ignore insertion snapping no
perpendicular snapping though is super
useful
um
let's say i have a line or rather we
already already have a line i want to
draw another line from somewhere here
let's say from the center of this circle
that would go
at 90 degrees angle to this line segment
right
so i want to start drawing a line from
here
from the middle
and i want it to snap
to 90 degrees which is going to be
somewhere here probably
over here
uh i want to snap it at 90 degree angle
to this line so the way i do it is i
enable i'll escape out of that enable
perpendicular snapping
like this
grab the line tool
start drawing
and then it will give me where the
perpendicular snap is once i click there
hit enter
i can see that between these two lines i
have 90 degree angle
really really useful stuff if you want
to
let me delete that if if you want to for
instance if you have more
circles here
and you need to
kind of find the 90 degree snap from
these two circles to this circle for
instance
you can always do that and then kind of
continue on finding the snaps
to
that's a very tight fit for that i need
to zoom in but yeah
right
so that's quite useful
um let me get rid of those two lines
though
right so so that's
perpendicular or in other words 90
degree snapping
then we have tangent snapping tangent
snapping is basically
um it's much easier for me to show than
it is to
actually
explain
let's say we have well we already have a
circle here
and let's say we want to draw
we have one more circle here uh we want
to draw from the middle of the circle
from here
a line that's going to seamlessly
connect
to the circle right here that is called
the tangent line right and let me make
sure that i have it turned on i don't
tangent there we go now we have it
turned on
and now i can draw from the middle
and find
this icon here tangent
click
enter
so now as the circle is going here
it will seamlessly transition to this
line
and actually uh visually explaining it i
think
uh let me do one thing i will explain
that tool in
later stages of of this project or of
this tutorial
but
let me just do do this real real quick
this line and the way it connects to the
arc is now seamless there there is no
sharp corner right so that's a tangent
let me undo that
engines are quite uh quite useful
in that regard
um
right
i don't know what i'm what i'm drawing
here
something something weird
something weird for sure
so we have tangents right
maybe one goes here maybe one goes here
sure why not
um
next
next next next next next
nearest snap
oh and that's actually going to be the
last one because apparent intersection i
don't like that kind of snapping i
prefer
a different work method so i will not be
showing that nearest snapping is quite
quite useful once you have it turned on
and you want to create a circle just
somewhere on this line it will
constantly give you
the nearest point to that line right or
nearest point here
right or nearest point here right so you
can kind of just
create a bunch a bunch of of of circles
on on another well if you actually don't
don't if you don't miss it
see enter
a bunch of circles
on already existing geometry right
so that's actually any point that is
closest will be fetched by the nearest
snapping um
that's about it that's about it in in
terms of snapping tools
um the
key thing is you don't want to have all
of the snapping tools enabled because it
gets too convoluted it tries to
suggest too many ways of how you can
snap to geometry and it
it becomes a little bit tricky a little
bit bothersome to to work around
work around that so usually what i like
to do is i like to turn off tangent
snapping i like to turn on off sorry
intersection quadrant snapping geometric
center and center and i just leave end
point midpoint perpendicular and nearest
snapping those are the mostly used ones
if i need some other snapping method i
will enable it just for that particular
tool
a shortcut of how to turn on or off
object snapping is f3
button f3 uh but yeah usually i just
always have it turned on
oh beautiful graphics that we've made
here all right so that is snapping right
and that is snapping let's take a look
if everything is
all right here
that's the same thing here uh
in this workspace as well
good very
good um right
so next up we have
the different ways of how you can modify
geometry right
so you can move it you can copy it you
can rotate scale it mirror it trim it
extend it blah blah
let's go through them
let's go through them and once we are
yeah once we are done with this
then we will start drawing our house
little by little
right so first thing is move right
that's a pretty simple one let's say i
want to
i have this geometry here i don't know
which one to choose let's see all of
this i have i want all of this to move
away
or to move somewhere uh maybe to snap to
uh to this point right here right i can
do that by selecting all of it typing in
m
hitting enter m short for move hitting
enter
giving it saying
the base point so
clicking where i want the base point to
be and i actually want the base point to
be in the middle right and i can't
select the middle because i turned off
the object snapping so i will actually
go in here and turn on center snapping
right here
so now i can select the middle
click
and now i can move it
again if you can only move it
horizontally or vertically then you need
to hit f8 or turn off ortho snapping
orthographic snapping
um
so i can move it now
and i will just move it let's say to
here doesn't matter or maybe to the
midpoint here yeah sure to the midpoint
here i'll just move it to the midpoint
here click again that's it
it's now located here right
um also
just like move there is copy i can
select the geometry i can type in copy
cop
i think yeah c o okay c o is enough but
i use cop for some reason
co
enter
again from the midpoint let's say to
ah for now i'll just kind of make a few
copies
uh horizontally so i'll just hit f or
vertically i'll just hit f8
click
click if you want to copy or move
something by a fixed amount
then instead of just clicking you first
describe the
direction let's see it's my horizontal
direction towards here and then you type
n by how much so i will just say by 500
millimeters enter
well that's not a lot but you get the
idea right so
the initial geometry was copied to the
side by 500 millimeters
okay
that's move and copy then we have scale
scale is basically just changing the
size of the object
you can either scale a single object
select one
scale
type in scale or sc
word for scale enter
and then select the point around which
you're going to scale the object from
which you're going to enlarge or shrink
the object so let's say it's going to be
this corner point right here or the
middle of the circle doesn't matter this
corner point right here and i'll just
say that the scale needs to be
five
right
five is five hundred percent five times
larger right so this guy becomes five
times larger
i'll ctrl z to undo
i'll select it again
and i'll scale
again around the same point but this
time around i'm going to say 0.5
that is 50
not 500 that is half of the size right
so it gets
shrunken down
that scaling
um nothing nothing fancy about it
then we have i believe mirror right
yes we have mirroring so mirror is quite
cool let me get rid of this
let's say you already have this geometry
done
or not done but you have some sort of
geometry and you want to mirror it to
the other side usually you do that with
doors and whatnot uh but let's just say
you want to mirror it i can select all
of it and type in mi hit enter am i
short for mirror hit enter
and then it's going to give ask me to
draw a mirror line so it's basically
going to be like the line
around which it's going to mirror it's
much easier to show than to
than to kind of talk about it so that's
my mirror line let me hit f8 to turn it
off and now it's i think it's even
easier to see what's going on right
so now i can mirror this
quite useful
right
that's my mirroring
and i can do this uh
this way
oh yeah and once you're finished
mirroring it's going to ask you would
you like to erase source objects or no
so would you like to delete the initial
one or would you like to keep it i will
say don't erase just keep it so no
so we have mirrored this right and i can
kind of do it again
mirror
let's say between these two points like
that enter
right now i have this kind of geometry
going on
um
let me just double check
here
whatever any kind of geometry
i select all of it
mirror
here
well
in case of here it doesn't ask you right
next to the cursor but it asks you
um here in the in the command line would
you like to erase source objects yes or
no by default it said to know so you
just hit enter and you know it's done
so that works in in in both versions as
well
so that's mirroring
i really want to draw a line here so i
will
um maybe not from there maybe from here
to here
i don't know
i i i just think it's it's uh it's gonna
look better if if we have some some
geometry in between
so that's that that that is basically
mirroring
next
trim trim and extend okay
so for trimming i actually need to show
it with a much simpler example and then
we'll go in here and kind of i'll show
you how to trim stuff in here
uh so a very simple example would be i
have a circle
i have a line
right
and the line crosses the circle i want
to get rid of this line segment that is
inside
of the circle
i can type in tr
trim
enter it's going to
tell me to select objects
and unfortunately it doesn't say
what kind of objects
or
select all so i can just hit enter
to say select all
enter right and it's then just going to
say okay what would you like to trim so
i want to trim this right i just hover
my mouse over it and you can see that
it's gone if i click it's really gone
right so i can trim it away so what it
does what trimming does it finds
intersections right into intersection
moments and it deletes geometry
inside of those intersection moments
or not necessarily inside because you
can do
you can do something like this
pr enter enter
double enter remember
and then click here
click here right
it just finds the intersections and kind
of delete stuff that's that's sticking
out or going in so
you're basically erasing segments
uh in that way
so if if i were to look at the more
complex uh more complex example let's
say i want to clean this up
i can say tr enter
enter and then then i can just kind of
go to town and keep keep deleting this
and i'll purposely make a mistake or not
a mistake but i'll i'll do a thing that
always happens
and i'll keep kind of going here and
trimming away
all of these segments
and at a certain point i can't anymore
well i can still trim away this one i
think yes
but now i can't trim well i can't trim
this there we go
now i can't trim anything else never
mind now i can't trim anything else
there we go so these two segments here
right can't be trimmed and the reason
for that is they they both meet at their
end points so there's no way for me to
kind of you know these are full segments
that are meeting
in their endpoints and they're not being
crossed by any geometry right so the
trimming will not work on them so then i
just kind of select them and delete them
right so that they get trimmed away
uh as you're using trimming
pr enter it will you you can choose to
select objects rather than selecting all
so i can select for instance these two
objects hit enter and now
everything that i trim
right it's just going to be trimmed by
those two objects and why can't i trim
this
i can it's just i need to zoom in
fair enough
right um and of course it can also
you can also trim objects themselves
so these are like active objects during
trimming um
what that means is that i can't when i
do it that way i can't just jump in here
and start trimming it won't let me
because it's
it it has nothing to do with with these
this geometry right here so i do prefer
using tr enter and then just hitting
enter again
and then going
going in here and trimming away
um anything that i
that i want in any part of the drawing
right
much much more convenient for me with
that select all method
right
that's that's that let me just clean it
up because i like stuff when it's clean
there we go
okay
uh wait nope
er enter enter
yeah almost
almost forgot about these two there we
go now now it's fine
um
so that's trimming
that is uh that is trimming then we have
extend
extend is basically if you have a
polyline and it's doing this and you
have another one and it's doing this and
you want this polyline to
elongate until it hits
this power line right or this line
segment elongate until it hits this line
segment that is extend
ex
enter
it's going to ask us to either select
objects or select all this time around i
always select the objects and these are
the objects
towards which i'm going to extend right
so first i then select this line segment
right
i hit enter
and that's important and then i can
click
on my other line segment and it's going
to be extended towards this object right
so that's how extend works um
there are some cases where it's of
course not going to work for instance if
i just say line
and i want to and i have this line and i
want this line segment
to extend towards this one it won't work
right if i extend
enter select this line segment enter
and then try to select this line it will
not work it will not extend that's
because
the
there's no way for this line to extend
so that it hits this line segment
uh which actually
brings us to
uh
let's see if it brings us to yes it does
it brings us to another tool that's
called fillet and the shortcut for it is
f
f
enter
fill it
right uh so fillet
basically extends two line segments
until they
meet
at a corner right
let's see this guy and this guy if i
fled them
you
and you
they get filleted into a corner
the reason why it's called fillet is
because you can change the radius of the
corner right so it doesn't need to be a
sharp corner let me ctrl z to undo
and let me fill it again
fill it
or
i write the full thing f enter
and here i'll just say
radius i'll click on the radius or type
in r enter it doesn't matter if you
click on or type in r
and here i can specify a radius so i'll
give it like 500
millimeters i have no idea how long
those slides are but i i assume 500
millimeters will work
100 hit enter
and now i will
click
on the top line
click on the bottom line
and you get filleted
quite nice huh
quite nice
and it gives us a fillet of
radius of 500 millimeters
so that's how fillet works
um there's also like options for
uh fillet where we can see that
now there's no options for fillet where
we can
never mind nevermind
ignore ignore what i said uh i thought
that it was the same as in rhino but
it's not so
just radius for now we will just be
using radius delete that so let's fill
it
the left doesn't work
with
objects
that are
of
parallel
because there's no way for you to extend
to objects that are parallel to lines
that are pale
okay
okay apparently it does work
what the hell okay wait fill that
the let radius zero whatever it is is
zero will it not work then it still
works that's a smart cookie so then if
you have two objects that are parallel
and you try to fill it them even if the
radius you specify the radius to be zero
it's going to create an arc that
connects the two objects that's nice
that's a that's a new functionality of
autocad that wasn't there before
definitely wasn't there before let's see
it in the older version of autocad if
that's also the case
well older version 2019 is not that old
uh one line segment another line segment
the let
come on fill it
let
from here
here yeah it does work here as well cool
okay
i'm learning something new as well
so if you have two parallel line
segments apparently it's going to just
create an arc between them with the
fillette
even if you say you don't want any
radius for the fillet to have
cool
uh what's next next up we have
zoom extent okay so that's an important
one
um wait oh wrong wrong wrong autocad
let's say here
right i i've been working on this and i
have
zoomed out
zoomed out and i must mess it up and i
have no idea where i am right i have
absolutely no idea what i where i am
uh so what you can do
is you can say ctrl a
to select all
so ctrl a
selects
everything
that you have in your drawing
and then what you can do is you can type
in z enter
[Music]
e
enter
and it's going to zoom in to the
geometry that you have selected so
if you're lost in your drawing then ctrl
a z enter e enter really helps but also
it's quite useful where
when you have like multiple drawings on
one one sheet then just
saying well let me
copy
bam
um fade bam bam let's say you have
multiple drawings on one sheet and just
so that you don't need to zoom in zoom
out
uh what you can do is you can just
select z enter e enter oh sorry in this
case it would be z enter
s enter
selected
oh enter
i'm a little bit rusty apparently
yes okay so it's going to be selecting
the object
z enter o enter
[Music]
zoom to object so zoom extends
i made a mistake during this tutorial
zoom extents you don't need to do
control a you don't need to select all
of the geometry it already recognizes
where that the geometry is as if it's
selected so z enter e enter extends will
zoom into all of the uh geometries on
your scene in your in your model
model file automatically you don't need
to select all of them beforehand
that's useful
uh yeah forgot about that one i
apologize
the entry enter there we go we're zoomed
in
uh so that's that
zoom extents quite useful
and then we have array and hatch
these two i will show you later
once we have some geometry going on in
the rhino
this is an autocad course in the autocad
file
once you have some proper geometry going
on
then i'll show those two
then
um
let's draw a building enough of this
let's let's draw let's draw a plan
first right
so i will
i'll keep this why not i'll keep this
but here i'll start drawing my my
building
right so the first thing that you do
before you or actually no i will not
keep this i will
close this file all together or we can
we can just select it delete
there we go select the deleted
clean clean sheet you know to start with
the first thing that you do
before you start drawing is you check
the units we already did that right we
are drawing in millimeters
second thing that you do when you before
you start drawing is you create layers
in which you're going to be drawing it
so up till now we will we were drawing
in a single layer
right which was
the layer zero
autocad works in layers
and different
line thicknesses different line types
and line colors are described by
different layers right and you can turn
on and off
those layers it works in a similar way
as as photoshop actually
in this regard one more thing that i
didn't notice that autocad is vector
based rather than raster based so think
of it as
photoshop versus illustrator right
you're used to those too by now
photoshop uses pixels
while illustrator does it meaning that
you can zoom into geometry of
illustrator infinitely and it's not
going to change resolution or it's not
going to
it doesn't have a finite resolution
while um
while in photoshop if you zoom in too
close then you'll start seeing the
pixels right so any kind of 3d modeling
or drawing software
for for commercial use is going to be
vector based it means that your lines
are
infinite in in their resolution in their
quality
uh that's important to
know
okay layers right so how do we access
layers well they are located right here
the layers tab of course and you can see
here it's it's our active layer layer 0.
and if i expand this that's the only
layer that we have layer 0 and it says
it says that it's white but it's
actually black well it shows white
because we have a black background but
it's going to print out black
don't ask why
just go with it i'll explain the print
printing settings layer
if you want to add more layers we need
to go to layer properties
so i'll click on that layer properties
will open up this layer tab for
us which
let me expand it
and let me just make sure that you see
it there we go so here we have these
four icons create new layer freeze oh
wait new layer frozen oh create a new
layer that's frozen uh delete layer and
set
set layer to current we don't care about
these three we only care about creating
new layers so i'm going to be doing that
i'll click on this create new layer tab
i'll choose
and i'll say
thick
line
or or just thick
right so creating new layer calling it
thick
create one more layer
call it medium
and create one more layer call it thin
right so we have these three layers here
thick medium thin
great
what can you do with them you can turn
them on or off
you can freeze them and you can lock
them
for now just
ignore the freeze area just
think of it this way if you lock them
you can't select the geometry
of that particular layer in the viewport
which is quite useful when you have a
lot of stuff layered on top of each
other uh stuff that you don't want to
select
can be
locked which is
nice
then are those layers
printable can you print so that's the
plot area here
what kind of color do those layers have
what kind of what's the display color
and what kind of line type and line
weight
so we will be changing that in just uh
i guess in the next tutorial
but for now i'll just change the colors
just so that we can distinguish between
thick medium and thin right so the thick
layer i always like to
choose red from here
medium i always like to use blue
and thin i always like to use green
but it's absolutely up to you this is
just something that i'm used to
and as i'm drawing this is the way i
color code my lines
that's about it
right so we have our layers set up and
i'll keep the zero layer for now that's
that's fine that's okay
once we have them set up i can close
and now i can uh create or not not
create but i now i can expand this um
drop-down list of layers and i can
choose which one is going to be my
active one the one in which i draw so
i'll choose thick layer here
thick it's my active one and now as i
draw a circle for instance it's going to
be red because it lives in that layer
if i draw another one it's also red red
right all of them are red
um
if i want to change a layer of an object
all i need to do or multiple objects all
i need to do is just select them
and in the drop down list i just choose
the layer
right
once i hit escape
i'm back to my
to the active layer in which i'm drawing
but now the layers of these two objects
have been changed and i can see that it
blue might not go well with the
recording so i will go to layer
properties and change this blue to cn
right to cyan not c and cyan
uh just so that they pop a little bit
better
there we go so that is that's that
right uh working with layers really easy
in autocad let's start drawing so i'm
gonna start drawing in thick layer uh
with thick lines because i'm going to be
drawing a plan and i'm going to be
i'll start drawing from the walls right
or rather from the section of the walls
so
the plan
is cut
at 1.2 meters
yeah it's cut at 1.2 meters so that you
are cutting through windows above the
tables and whatnot so it's like a locked
locked number um you can always kind of
adjust the the height
you know
for different projects if there's a need
for that but the default
you know the default number that you
should have in your head is 1.2 meters
uh so that's how high we're going going
to be cutting our our plan
or our building and showing the plan uh
through the cut so
if we go into the course website and
kind of read through this
i can somewhere here
that's the course description that's the
deliverables
yeah there we go uh no matter which
client is chosen the building footprint
cannot exceed 25 square meters okay
that's like five by five sure but five
by five is is not that convenient for me
i'm thinking of a six by four perhaps
yeah sure let's do six by four uh we'll
we'll see how we can cram it in i
haven't planned it out in my head so it
might be a very crappy
very crappy building but this is just to
showcase uh
the way you work in autocad
um
right so
i need a
i'm going to have a building that has a
footprint of six by four meters six
thousand by four thousand millimeters so
i'm going to actually create a rectangle
r e c t rect
i'll start drawing it from anywhere
doesn't matter and i will say that i'm
going to draw it in dimensions rather
than just clicking somewhere else on the
screen so d enter
right the enter and then i type in the
length which is 6000 enter
um
did i not yes six thousand and now it
asks me for the width and the width is
going to be
four thousand
actually i can kind of get away with 4
200 but for now i'll just say 24 square
meters that's fine as well
4 000.
so and then i'll just choose that yeah
here whatever
there's the rectangle there
um so that's my that's my outer
footprint right outer footprint my walls
have thickness of course and for this i
will say that the wall thickness is
going to be
um
400 millimeters the outer wall thickness
around 400 millimeters
usually they are a little bit thicker
than that but
uh it's a summer house it's a pretty
small house so 400 is okay
uh so what i want to do
is actually i want this rectangle to go
inwards
to make a copy of this rectangle inwards
by
400 millimeters and there's a tool that
does that i will show it on the side
here real quickly if i have a polyline
or a line segment
and i use a tool that's called offset
offset
oh i think it's
yeah it's just o enter
and i type in the distance so here i'll
just type in 400 enter
then i can select the line segment here
and i can offset it to either side to
here or here this mirror
and click
and then i know that between these two
lines the gap is indeed
400 millimeters right so that's offset
really useful
uh
also works with polylines
offset
uh 400
like that right
if i were to draw the same shape or
similar shape
with line segments though
like that and then i did offset
keyboard come on
offset 400
then
since i drew this with polyline and this
with line tool this is exploded so that
means that my offset is going to be a
little bit more tricky
like that
right i will need to offset every line
separately and then i will need to tr
trim enter enter and trim away the
doodads here
right
clean it up
now they're kind of the same the only
difference is that this is exploded
while this is joined up right
so back here back to our plan i can just
do offset
400
and offset it inwards by 400 inwards
because
we are already at at 25 square meters
or 24 square meters so i can't offset it
outwards i need to opposite it inwards
right
so that's the
the thing that we are going to be
working with right that's our
inner area
not a lot of stuff
to work on
so let me just quickly plan this out
let's see we have
some sort of a block here
toilet shower room
entrance
and the work
okay
so
let's say i want a separate room here
right in this area
where i'm going to have my
bathroom my shower and
and whatnot in in in this particular
room
right
um and it's going to be a little bit of
an awkward room but that's going to work
out so
i am going to create a line segment
right and i'll just
kind of draw it out from this corner
point
to this corner point like so and hit
enter right so now what i have here is i
have a duplicate line right
there is this polyline here and also
this line segment
the reason why i do this is because now
i can take this line segment i can
select it if you have problem selecting
it you can always use the blue
marking tool
and just select it that way
um and i can type in offset
and let's say
how wide
how wide so the
smallest shower
that that is kind of nice still nice to
have
is around 900 millimeters so we can't
have it thinner like than that so i will
say 900
millimeters
such a
bad
bad space
though
such a bad space okay let's do instead
of 900 i will do
one meter at least yeah one meter it
creates an offset right and now for this
line so this is going to be
like a mark where my bathroom ends
so i want to make this into a wall so i
will offset it again i click on it and
i'll type in
140 millimeters
14 centimeters that's enough for the
inner walls
right
14 millimeters
and once i'm done
i just hit escape or enter doesn't
matter
and i have my
my two line segments that describe an
inner wall right here
i still do have that line segment here
that i use right but i don't need it
anymore so i'll just select it and hit
delete
just get rid of it all together
right
so that's my two line segments
now what i want is i want
to get rid of this
segment here
and this segment here so that is trim
right tr enter
enter
and then click
click enter
easy
right i've
just successfully
uh deleted those two segments and now i
have a room here and a room here i don't
have any doors or windows or anything
but i do have a room that's one meter
here and all of the remaining area is
located here
this is not clean anymore because
this pole line and this line segment are
two separate entities i want to join
everything up
so that this is a rectangle this is a
rectangle and this is a rectangle so
that i have three rectangles here so
i'll select all of it and type in join
hit enter
and yeah that that's it just join them
up right so now this is a rectangle
rectangle rectangle closed
very important that they are closed
so that is that
uh let's create an entrance doorway
right or
let's create a doorway into
into the bathroom right so i'm going to
create a line segment
just from here to here from the midpoint
to the midpoint because i want the door
to be
centered
and the door is 90 centimeters so so the
the width of the door is 90 centimeters
the height of the door is usually two
point in between 2.1 meters and 2.2
uh
depends
on on what kind of door you're using but
usually
uh
what i like to do is do 2.2 meter high
doors and add
if i need to then i add framing inside
so it kind of eats up a little bit a
little bit of that height either way we
have the line segment
i will offset it
um i'll specify the offset distance to b
because i want to offset it to
both sides it will be 45 centimeters so
450 millimeters hit enter
and now i can just
offset it up
and offset it down like that right
stay with me
i hit enter
now i don't need the middle segment
anymore so i can just select it delete
it
right
and i have these two segments now so
i'll say trim
enter
i'll just trim away
this oops
trim
enter enter
always forget to do the double enter
and i'll just trim away these two line
segments here
right
so now what i've done is i created an
opening
in the wall right for for the door to be
in
i can select all of this type in join
and now all of all of these segments are
joined so i have one polyline here
and one polyline here
great
let's do this again i will keep doing
this just so that you can follow along
quite quite easily so i want a door here
right
and i probably want so if there's a
shower here i do want to have a window
and there's a toilet here i do want to
have a window here right
um right so door window
okay i will create a line segment from
here to here
and i will offset it
by 900 millimeters to the side like so
trim
enter
enter enter rather
and then the same thing here
um actually
this one can be the the same size as the
door
so i'll just kind of
be cheeky about it and just start
drawing from
from the doorway like so
trim
enter enter
tr not trim god damn it i keep
forgetting tr
for trimming and i create an opening
here
so door door window and it's probably
going to have a window somewhere here
but we'll kind of take care of that side
layer
okay
the thing is well first of all let's
let's clean everything up by selecting
the walls and joining them up
just so that this is closed and this is
closed right so everything is kind of
neat and dandy
the thing is that here
while
we are cutting through
the doorway here we don't see the bottom
of the doorway all we see is just kind
of floor floor floor floor but here the
window probably will not reach the floor
right
so that means that we will see the
window sill right we will see the bottom
of the window opening in the plan
and i can uh not can i need to show it
right so i'm going to go to
the layers and i'll say that
the layer in which i'm going to draw is
the medium layer so let let's talk about
this just a second
thick
layer is used to specify all of the
lines which you get
from
cutting something right so i'm cutting
the walls
right and i'm looking at the cut of the
walls
meaning that they will be shown thick in
the thick line
medium line is stuff that you
see as a projection right so you're not
cutting through it but you can still see
it so in this case uh if i have a
if i have a window
oh my god wait just bear with me
sure that's that's fine
so let's say i have a window um
you know that that has some sort of
partition
partitioning whatever
is just a window right in in the in the
facade
and i am cutting through that window
like so
right at this height i'm cutting through
it and i'm looking at it
downwards i'm looking at the cut
you know straight downwards
that means that i i will see the frame i
will be cutting through the frame i will
be cutting through the glass
frame again and then wall right so wall
frame glass
frame wall but also i will be seeing
the hole
here right i will be seeing the the
windowsill
so
that windowsill is not a cut rather it's
just a projection it's just something
that i see
meaning that i
use a medium line
grab a line tool and i just draw it from
here
to here
enter or either let's just draw a
rectangle instead
might as well polyline tool
like that that
that
that that
that's the windowsill right
and i still i still have the red lines
um
above it i guess like the cut above it
it's just that visually
autocad needs to choose which kind of uh
geometry to show
uh
if there's like two geometries on top of
each other so you just choose to show
the medium one but we don't care because
we know that we have the thick line
above it
and my camera died
just a second
god damn it
yeah yeah yeah
you're good
all right
we're good okay
so that's the window windowsill right
now for the frame
uh we'll do the frames in the next
tutorial um
for the doors as well right
uh as long as we have the windows so
it's fine one more thing is we have the
floor slab right and then we have the
outside you know the ground the gravel
and so on those are
things that are in two different heights
and two different levels right because
usually you have like a step or two
steps near the entrance and blah blah
which means that
there's a a line where the floor slab
ends right where where the floor just
ends we need to mark that line so i'll
use the line tool and just mark it here
that's where my floor slab ends
right
so we have that going on now
nice
um
we will be adding doors here the next
tutorial a toilet
shower
it's a little bit
it's going to be a little bit tricky to
plan out but i we'll we'll figure it out
we will figure it out for now um
this is all that you need to do
practice
practice the lines practice the tools
and so on and draw out the
just the walls
with
the openings shown right properly
so this is that one
this is the level of detail that
that you should have
after the first day of tutorials
next up i will not need to show you
every tool
uh so we will
make a lot of more progress in terms of
of drawing in the next tutorial
for now
get to work
and have fun
bye
all right hello
hello and this is going to be the second
part of our tutorial series for router
cat
where i'm going to
kind of continue on working on the plan
and hopefully we'll move
more forward with the section and so on
so in the first part i've already showed
you most of the
most of the tools that we're going to
use
so here it's just designing right it's
it's just adding geometry into our plan
so let me
let me keep the camera there that's fine
should be okay
okay
so we finished off by creating openings
here for the window for the doors and
whatnot and creating a little
room for our sink to be in
well it's probably going to be somewhere
here the shower
and the toilet
show
let's continue
so the
the thing that i want to do is probably
add the
a little bit more detail into the window
a little bit more detailing to the doors
and and whatnot and then continue on
working with this area right here
so first of all i'm going to create a
window so remember where i showed you
before if you have a window
like that
and i'll just draw it in
in lines without any thicknesses
let's say you have you know a regular
window in a facade
and it's in the hole in the wall right
and you're cutting through it like so
so
[Music]
and you're looking down
on it
right you're looking downwards through
the cut you're cutting through the wall
right here
and right here
you're cutting through the wall you're
cutting through the glass and you're
cutting through the frames of the window
so if you have divisions
you would be cutting through the middle
frame as well but i think for a window
this size we don't need any divisions
it's just going to be
is lagging
let's do
it's just going to be this kind of
window
so we're going to cut through the frame
here through the glass here through the
frame here right let's do that a window
frame what i prefer to use is
five by five centimeters right it's not
accurate but that is enough for our
level of detail that we're going to be
using
so
since we're cutting through the frame
i'm going to be using a thick line right
and i'm actually going to just draw the
the cut of a frame anywhere on on the
screen doesn't matter click apollo line
tool
just hit that f8 button or ortho or two
snapping on
so that it's horizontal or vertical and
i'll just give it 50 enter to the side
50 enter
side 50 enter
there we go
something like that
so
you could do a rectangle but i just i
don't know i'm used to drawing it in
polyline
now
we need to take this frame and place it
in the middle
of this opening here right
on this side and on this side
so i'm gonna take the frame
i'm going to move it m
enter
and i'm going to move it from its let's
say top middle point here
all the way out to
the middle point right here
right here there we go
click
now it's here
then i just take it i copy it
by by using the command copy for some
reason it's not
making a copy i don't know why let's try
again copy
from here
to here
there we go
now we have a cut through the frame
right
so
this area right here
is done
and this area right here is done
now we will be cutting through the
window as well through the glass sorry
as as well and for the glass since it's
uh
this is just graphics but i prefer to do
it this way since we are indeed cutting
through the glass you would think that
we will be using a thick line
but
since
glass is inherently transparent i prefer
to use a medium line thickness for it
just so that it's not too thick right
um
so let me jump to the medium layer
and just draw a line
from the midpoint here
to the midpoint here so that is our
glass in the window
the thing is
that if
you think about it
we are cutting indeed cutting through
the glass
but we are also seeing the bottom of the
frame right here right this this edge
right here will be seen
right which means that here we need two
more lines to show the bottom of the
frame
and for those two lines
uh since i'm using a medium line to show
the cut through the glass
i will be showing those two lines that
we actually see at the bottom of the
window
uh as
a thin line right i will represent it
with a thin line
the reason why i'm doing this
uh the reason why i'm doing this is
because
once we print it out
or plot it out as a pdf
and we have it zoomed out i don't want
these three lines to merge into one
thick one right
or just just because we are so zoomed
out and the thicknesses eat each other
up right so i have them
separated
into two thin lines and one medium line
rather than thick and two medium lines
which would be a little bit more
accurate but wouldn't represent the
window that well
that's basically it we we have a window
now right we have the glass the bottom
of the frame
and the cut through the frame
right here
okay window is done
now the door
[Music]
perhaps we should use
where where do we on which door do we
start working on
let's work on this one right
so the door is
it's basically drawn um i can show you
somewhere here
the door is basically just drawn
as
always being opened
unless it's a
re
reconstruction project and you already
have existing doors in the previous
project which you reconstruct then those
doors are usually shown half opened
at 45 degree angle but in this case
since these are new doors we are going
to be showing them at
completely opened at 90 degrees
angle from the
from the wall
and they will
incorporate a door swing like so right
well not like so actually
i'm going to make this quite fast
like that
so it's going to be
the door swing showing the travel of the
door when you open it up
as well as the door itself being open
the door is shown in a neckline because
you're cutting through the door
and the opening
of the door is shown in the thin line
because it's a non-existing
geometry right it's it's something that
you just use as a markup to show the
travel so you don't even need to have a
medium line for that it needs to be a
thin line
so that kind of doorway needs to be here
needs to be incorporated here so the way
i i really like doing it
is
by creating a line line two
here
um
do we do it that way
maybe we want a little bit of an offset
okay let's first do a little bit of an
offset so i will create a line or or
rather two lines
from here to here
and from here to here
these two line segments and i will give
them a little bit of an offset uh five
centimeters at most we can do even less
we can do two centimeters it's up to you
but i prefer using five so five
centimeters enter
i'll just offset
that line inwards like so by five
centimeters and that line inwards like
so also 50 millimeters five centimeters
so now we have um
these two
floating lines here and these two
guidelines that we first had i don't
need them anymore so i can delete them
so
so this is a bracket in which our door
is going to be held
and treat these two lines as your helper
helper lines
right we will be deleting them later on
so now what i do is i create
a straight line segment in a thick layer
from the midpoint here
to the midpoint here
like that
right
i select it and now i want to open up
the door right so uh this doorway
or this door
board i want to rotate it right so i'm
going to use a tool that's called rotate
rotate enter
it's going to ask me to for a point
around which i'm going to be rotating so
let's say the door
hinge is right here
that point
and basically then i can
just
either move it like so move the mouse
like so and click or i can type in
90 degrees
and hit enter well
not 90 sorry
minus 90.
so apparently
if if you add positive values it's going
to rotate counterclockwise if you had
negative values it's going to rotate no
sorry
negative values are clockwise positive
values are counterclockwise
so again rotate select this object
enter rotate around here minus 90
degrees
there we go so now it's it has been
opened and now all i need to do is just
create that arc right
so i can either use
a circle tool and trim away stuff
from the circle tool or i can just use
arc
well let me show you it then in both
ways so let me do it with the circle
tool first i will create a circle
from here
to here from the midpoint here to the
end of the door here
i will create one more line
from midpoint here
midpoint here
like that
and now i will trim
enter
enter again
and i'll just get rid of
the unnecessary parts
of the circle to just get that
arc there and now i can delete
all of the necessary stuff and change
the arc of of the
[Music]
the doorway
right
of the door's wing
so that's that um i will show another
method of how to create that arc
in this version here because we need a
doorway here
so
let me do the same thing first
from here to here we have a line segment
from here to here we have a line segment
i offset them
50 millimeters offset words inwards
escape out
delete the trash or the helper lines
like that create a line segment
ma'am something like this
rotate
that and this time around it's going to
be counterclockwise so it's just going
to be 90 degrees like that
and now what i can do is i can just
create an arc let's say arc tool or a
enter
and i will say that
the center point of the arc
or rather i will not be using start
point
of an arc but rather i will be using
the center mode or the arc tool so i'll
click on that
in the bottom
which will ask me to give it a center so
the center is going to be located right
here
where the door starts right here
and i'm just going to draw an arc from
this point
to this point
that's it that's that's an arc that has
been created now we clean up the trash
again
and change the arc layer to thin
that's it so those are two two different
methods of how you can
actually
use the
or how you can add the arc
sorry about this yeah that's fine
okay
moving on
so we have uh two doorways we have a
window perhaps i want a window here as
well but first of all i need to plan out
how my
whole
room is going to look like so let's say
we enter here we will need some place to
put down our codes and we will need some
sort of a place for a for a bed and it's
just going to be a small bed because we
can't have
a large bed here
so let me just create uh just to see the
proportion of the room let me just
somewhere else on the screen uh let me
just create a size of a bed that that i
want and it's going to just be
i'm drawing it with polyline 2 100
millimeters long
um
i'll go for
one mirror 10
100 millimeters wide
210
or 200
and close off the pole line so that's my
bed and it's going to be in the medium
medium layer
i'm just going to move it
somewhere here and start planning out
how how everything is going to be kind
of arranged and how everything is going
to look like
that's not great
let's see let's see let's see if we can
make it better i'll rotate this
from here
here
there we go
reposition this to here that's a little
bit better
we can have uh
a table here but the door is going to be
obnoxious
that's fine we can we can flip the door
around let's see
how wide the table is going to be so i
can check the distance here i can
measure the distance by typing in dist
sort for distance
enter and clicking on two points so from
here
to here
give me the distance and right next to
my cursor or
also above my command line well we can't
see it anymore there
i will see the distance so let me try
that again
1960 millimeters 1.9 meters that's a lot
that's that's uh that's quite enough
for shelving and also the
the table
so i'm going to do that i'll create a
polyline and i will say that my table is
let's go for a pretty thin one let's go
for 600 millimeters
600 enter
until here here
here
there we go
and this block is just going to be
representing my
my table right
so bed table there's gonna be a chair
here and then this door
is
in the way right it's just messing
everything up so what i'm going to do is
i will mirror this door uh so that it
opens up here the way i do that is just
i'll create a line
in the opening
just to have the midpoint of the line
i will select the door
i'll type in mirror
and then i will use the midpoint of that
line
i'll mirror the door horizontally like
so and when it asks me to resource
objects i'll actually say yes
right so that it deletes the old version
that's it now it has been mirrored quite
easy
um as you can see most of the time i
have orthographic snapping turned on for
this project
um yeah that that is how it is
okay
so we enter
really hate the
entrance here though
like the flow is really bad
i'll solve this later
i'll solve this layer
i think there's there's there are ways
of how to solve this
um but for now let's continue
so now i need a kitchenette right so
kitchen cabinets are always have
kitchen cabinets always have the same
module size and it's always 60 by 60
centimeters so the refrigerator the
stove the
the sink
cabinet all of them have 60 by 60
centimeters that's the
not regulation but the
default value let's see
so i'll switch to medium and i'll just
create that single rectangle of 600 mil
by 600 mil
by 600
like that
that's our
single segment for the kitchen
and i'm thinking of having the kitchen
right here
right so that's let's say that's our
refrigerator puppy
that's going to be our
sink our
stove
and
or rather maybe maybe the stove is here
the fridge is here the sink is here and
the cutting area and
food preparation area is here right so
we have that
that's good enough i think that's good
enough and now i can add
one more wall right here
just just for
how do i call it
just a separation you know kitchen from
the entrance also it will create a
little bit of a hallway here
just fine
um so i will create a polyline
i'll just draw out well let's go for
thick line i'll draw out a wall but i
don't really know how long the wall can
be
so what i'm going to do is i will create
an offset for the bed
offset
for the bed and i'll give it like 900
millimeters
like that
right so now i know that this gap right
here is walkable and it's it's easy to
to kind of walk through and
um
yeah
so basically i am able to walk around it
so now i know that the longest
um wall that i can have is something
like this right in the gap between here
um i will create a polyline now
draw it out like so
i'll give it
140 millimeters
to the side and finish up here finish it
up here
and now i don't need the helper line
anymore so i can delete it so that is my
second partition
right here
which i think is fine
you enter you put down your close you
can work you can sleep
you can use the stove
or you can prepare food
and you eat where you work yeah that's
fine that's that's reasonable i think
um here right here
i have a line segment that i don't need
in the wall because you know my wall
kind of continues on here so i'll just
trim it away trim enter enter
get rid of that
and then i'll join up
these two line uh these two separate
segments this one and this one i'll just
type in join to join them up and make it
at a closed
uh polar line to to just have it clean
okay
uh once you enter you want to put down
your clothes somewhere so i will create
um
a little bit of a
shelf i guess not not a shell
let's just call it close storage right i
will create that and it's going to be
um let's go for 500 millimeters
500 mil
like that
i have no idea how long this is so i
need to actually before i create that uh
that area right there i need to
measure distance
from here to
here 1.2 meters
we have 1.2 meters for that
uh sure 1.2 by
500 millimeters so 1200 by 500 sure um
i'll switch to medium line and i'll just
draw it out from here to here 500
here to here
this is where we put our clothes right
um
now i really want to solve this because
this is kind of obnoxious that you need
to close have the door closed of course
you most of the time will have the door
closed and it's going to work but
visually it's not that nice so i am
going to
probably create a
toilet here
and see how far i can move this doorway
away from the
uh away from the desk
so the toilet is well actually for the
toilet you can consult neufert
or you can just go to google
let's just type that in real quick
just give me a second
just a second there we go
google uh
toilet
dimensions
dimensions
images sure
why not
and just find any image here and then
you can see 690 by
35 let's see so 69 centimeters by 35
centimeters sure
i'll just draw it out as a rectangle for
now because all i care about is just the
size we will make it nice later
uh
690 uh in well
350 in width
619 length
350
90 there we go
something like that
and just place it here
which means that we do have
a little bit of room for this to move
out
and i think we will we will use that
i think we will use that
should we use that
yeah maybe we should
uh so i'm just going to move everything
to the to the side a little bit the way
you do that is
well
you can just kind of select these two
um
these two polylines here and notice
where where we have these points here i
believe we can just kind of move those
points around can't we
let's see
yes we can click on those points on
those corners and just move them up and
i'll just move them up by just sli a
tiny bit um
do i want to do that
sorry sorry about this i i need to
to design it in my head real fast do i
want to move now i mean i do like the
center composition here but maybe we can
break the center composition
nah i'll i'll keep it i'll keep it so
i'll escape out of this
and it's lagging escape
i'll actually keep it that's fine
it is what it is right the the opening
when when the door here is opened you
can't go through here but that is
that is the bane of uh small small
houses
uh my thoughts were that i could move
this opening towards somewhere here
until here
and then
uh
flip the door uh around again mirror it
back to what it was before and then you
will have a smooth transition and into
the
the toilet the bathroom but it's
it's not ideal
it's definitely not not ideal as well so
might as well just keep it the way this
is
it's fine
let's just move on
so we have our toilet here the shower
i don't even think we need to create a
like a separate separate shower cabinet
i think we can deal with this part here
as a as a shower uh cabin
uh in general so that's fine
it will have
a mark
which shows that you know that the
shower ends here and let me just
measure the distance real fast
how wide is it it's one meter wide so
it's a pretty damn wide shower
we can actually
we don't need it to be that wide do we
well
we kind of do because if we put a sink
here
then we need a gap here yeah so so okay
we will have a pretty large shower
um but the depth of it is a little bit
too big i think
let's see the distance
1.15 meters um that's actually
reasonable usually the like the smallest
shower that you can have
is
800
by 800
by 8
800 by 800 millimeters so something like
this so
here what we have is basically just a
larger larger shower that's fine that's
fine
um maybe i will indeed move this line
back by
a negative
or not negative just 150 millimeters
so it's near by a meter a little bit
cleaner right so this is where our
shower is i think we have it planned out
i think that's that's good enough
now just adding a few
bits and pieces here to the walls
to make it a little bit more
[Music]
lively here
okay so as you're preparing food you
will want a window
for sure so i will be creating a window
here
from here
until here
there's gonna be a window
and let me just immediately make it
thick line and let's draw it in a thick
line there's going to be like a long
window here
and also you want a window for
for the desk uh depending if you're
using a computer or not um
sometimes you don't want the window
directly on the desk so my thoughts are
what if we do
what if we do a window that is
straight up
a corner window
so it starts here
and it's going to end here right so
instead of that line it's just going to
be a window all the way around and it's
going to be like a corner corner window
i think that's going to look cool
uh so might as well do it and also it's
going to be a little bit more of a
challenge for us to actually
make it nice so
window right now i have a lot of stuff
here that i don't really need to see so
i'm going to expand my layers tab and
i'll hide the thin line and the medium
line layers by just clicking on the
light bulbs here so now they're hidden
uh just so that it's it's kind of easier
for me to
to work with this
i will
trim away
trim
enter enter trim away
this whole portion
of the
of the building because that's where my
window is going to be
i'll make sure to join everything up
so that this is
a single
polyline and this is a single polyline
sorry
and i'll turn on the medium layer again
and make it my active one and i will
draw out
from here to here i'll draw out the
window sill
it's gonna be something like that
right
something like that
and now all i need to do is just fill it
the window sill into a corner right so
i'll make sure that the radius is set to
zero so fillet
r enter r short for radius enter
zero enter so i made sure that there's
no rounding
and i will just fill it this with this
come on with this line enter to repeat
the flat command and i'll fill it this
with this
there we go so they they get kind of
extended and filleted into one
one area
or or one polyline
well they are not one pole line yet uh
these are two separate polylines that
make a corner so i'll actually create a
polyline here
or or a line segment right there here
and here
i'll select
all four of these lines
that and
that and i'll join them up
join
that's it now it's a single
single closed polyline great
so we have that
now on to creating the window frames
well to do that
i will be using
reusing this window frame here window
frame cut here so i'll just copy it
i'll copy it from the side midpoint
right here
to the midpoint right here
there we go that's that's one frame
that's being cut i'll also make a copy
to the other side of the window
from the bottom midpoint here to the
midpoint here
like that
right now i need to know
where exactly is the frame going to be
located here in the corner and the way i
do that is i'll just draw out two helper
lines
like that
and like that
so it goes from
around the outer perimeter of the frame
so from this point
as well as from this point
and they meet up in this corner meaning
that now if i take this
and i copy
copy it from its corner point here
to the corner
here
this is going to be like a
clean transition clean 90
90 degree bend so i don't need the
helper lines anymore i have the
the corner frame located right here
uh usually the corner frames do have a
little bit more of a of a thickness to
them but in this case since we're
dealing with low
uh low detailing level for our plants we
don't really need to
to show that
that's fine the way it is now on to
adding more frames because this is a
pretty long window so it's going to have
partitions
i'm thinking of adding two partitions
here
so i will first measure the distance
between this
and
this and i get
3325 millimeters which is not great but
that's gonna do the trick i will just
run um
[Music]
calculator three three two five divided
by three
is one point one meters approximately
uh so what i'm going to do is i'm i'm
just going to take this frame and i'll
copy it
i'll copy that
that frame cut
downwards
by
one one
zero zero one point one meters
like that and i'll take the bottom frame
i'll copy it
upwards
by 1 1 0 0 enter
escape out of the copy
now i have like a pretty okay transition
here
and also i believe we do want at least
one um
window frame here in the middle so i'll
repeat the process distance
from here to here
uh that's two two two five two
five so that's going to be well
math is hard okay let me grab calculator
two five to five divided by two one two
six five so
i'll actually do this 1265.5
so i'll take this uh this frame right
here i'll copy it
to the side
2565 i believe
uh
no no no no no
uh
162 5.5 162 5.5
no oh god damn it
one two six five let's do it again
i messed that up
let me measure distance again goddammit
uh
two five two five right yeah two five
two five divided two one two six five
point five
copy
come on
copy
copy
here to here one two six five point five
enter
there we go
in the middle
there
okay so we have that done and actually
it's not going to be in the middle right
because the the frame itself has a
certain amount of thickness let me just
double check with measuring two
distances from here to here we have one
two one five point five and from here to
here we have
[Music]
one two five nine
point five
um
five nine point five one two one five
so that is going to be
[Music]
i need to just keep calculator open one
two five nine point five minus one two
one five point five
that's going to be 44 millimeters off of
an error so i'm just going to move this
further by 44
millimeters now it's in the middle
um you don't really need to
well sorry not 44 that's going to be 22.
you don't need to do this
uh now as i'm doing it you don't need to
do this it can be
in this stage it can be approximate it
doesn't need to be that precise um
but just wanted to
to kind of do it
just for purpose of of of being
methodical
okay frames are done now it's time for
glass so that's just line segments
from midpoint
midpoint here
cutting through the glass
mid to mid
mid
mid
mid to mid
that's done
and now
with thin line we'll
keep layer turned on so i had it turned
off so once i selected the thin line
layer it asked me to turn it on so i did
so with thin line layer uh i will create
two more
lines for each of the window window
frame
like that
like that
i'm just hitting enter to repeat the
command
so i'm finishing the command and then
hitting enter to repeat the last command
to kind of keep drawing the line
segments
that
that and
finally that okay we are done we have
our corner corner window that is
finished
all right so that is our initial plan
and that seems okay there's going to be
a sink here
um
[Music]
questionable design here maybe if we do
an arc it's going to be fine
let's do an arc
so i'm going to
or rather let's let's just do a poll
line first so i know that uh
the distance of this window is 900
millimeters right 900 millimeters wide
so i'm just going to make a sink that's
900
in in length
um and the width of it i actually want
to use like 400 millimeters because it's
just a sink
um
yeah sure let's use 400
900
400
there we go so we have our sink here and
i'll just
move it
m enter select objects enter from this
point to this point right i just kind of
move it and i'll place it in the medium
layer
like that and now um
these corners right here are kind of
obnoxious so what i'm gonna do is i will
round them off
as much as i can
so my thoughts are
i need to use fillet right
for this so i will use fillette
enter
and i know that this is 400 millimeters
so my radius cannot be larger than 400
because it will just break it will not
work right so i'm probably going to use
something like 300 millimeters i think
that's going to be enough so fill that
radius 300 enter
and then this line for let's with this
line by 300 then enter to repeat the
fillet this line let's move this line by
300
that's it
this is now a little bit better in terms
of
transit transition
um
what i really
would encourage you doing in in your
future projects is
uh where we have the
toilet
we have this this area which which holds
the water
this whole area right here can be hidden
in the in a wall right it can be placed
in the wall but the wall of course needs
to become thicker and as you place it in
the wall above it you also have um
possibility for shelves and and whatnot
you know for for all of the
you know toilet paper rolls and and so
on so i would encourage you to
in in your future projects just to do
something like this um
create a separate well in the medium
thickness is it medium yeah let's do
medium in medium thickness just create a
shelf
right
enter come on
just create a shelf that is around
millimeters maybe even less 200
millimeters wide
like that
like that
so the shelf
eats up
the bottom or the the last part of the
toilet
and
the only thing that is kind of sticking
out from the shelf
is the the bowl of of the toilet is just
more aesthetic it's just nicer right so
i'll just grab the polyline tool and
redraw just the bowl area of the toilet
um for that i do need to have
intersection snapping turned on
enter so that i can
so that i can start drawing from this
intersection point here and kind of
draw out this u shape here right and now
i can delete the old version
right
so this is just the bowl and let's fill
it let's let's make it nicer so i'll
fill it uh first i'll measure the
distance
from here to here
well or rather from here to here we have
350 millimeters so half of that is 175
millimeters so i'll do a fillet of 150
millimeters for both corners
let
our r enter
how much did i say 150 right 150
from here
to here 150 enter again from here to
here 150. so we have that
i will also close off this
polyline by just creating a line segment
here
and joining it with the rest of of the
bowl just to have it as a closed
polyline and i will offset
the bowl inwards by 50 millimeters five
centimeters just to have something like
that and now i will flat
uh these two corners here with a little
bit less of a
of a radius so radius is going to be
like 50 millimeters not more than that
just to make it a little bit nicer
so we have that and then just a small
circle
um the size of it doesn't matter the
positioning of it doesn't matter
just to to show maybe a little bit
bigger just to show drainage
come on yeah
around the center point uh 1.5 times
there we go
so we have a
toilet right
i what what graphically i like to do is
this toilet right here
i like to
make all of the inner lines thin while
the outer line is medium right we are
not cutting through the toilet
um here in the shelf in the case of the
shelf we are cutting through it but it
is a furniture piece meaning that we are
not going to be showing it
in a thick line with a thick line rather
it is going to be a medium line but it
is going to have this kind of markup
with a thin line this
this
right
that means that this is a shelf
okay same thing actually for this shelf
as well from here to here
and from here to here
right or cabinet i guess
so we have that done now for the sink
same procedure we offset
um
50 sure 50 is fine inwards
we fill that
radius 50.
um i wonder if that's gonna be enough
yeah that's enough actually
that like that i will create a drainage
hole here
i'll just snap to the middle area
that
and i'll create a
a tap you know where water flows from so
i'll create a tap
um i don't know 150 ml maybe
50 ml or no definitely not 50 ml 20 20
millimeters
150
something like that very simple uh you
don't need to
get rid of that you don't need to
have it super super precise
and this becomes a thin line as well so
that's our our sink for the shower room
i
think what we can do
is add a little bit of shelving here
just a tiny bit like
10 centimeters
like that
uh well
that will need to be medium this is for
shampoo bottles and and all of that good
stuff
something like this
uh then create just a circle somewhere
i'll just snap to the midpoint let's see
here and i'll say that the circle is 200
millimeters in radius
and just move it
probably somewhere here
so that's the shower
shower head right which will
pour water okay
the bathroom is done
the bathroom is indeed done
let's move on to
the
bedroom slash workroom slash kitchen
slash dining room slash living room
um
to the rest of the space
i'll i'll kind of work on this
real quick so i said that i want to have
maybe refrigeration can go here so
refrigeration is basically just um
it's marked out like so
like that
then you take all of these lines and you
scale them scale
to the center point by
0.3 let's see
like that
that's refrigeration
uh then you have uh
so you take your food out you kind of
wanna place it
and then
it's a little bit cramped
okay you take the food out do you want
to place it immediately or do you have
placement here and you cook here
and then wash here
take out wash
cook
place take out wash place cook yeah so
okay so this is going to be a sink
and for the sink i'm just going to let's
let's just draw draw out some sort of
polyline that's going to be
um
the width of the sink let's say it's 500
millimeters the length of the sink or
the
sorry the length of this thing is 500
millimeters the depth of the sink is
going to be like 300 millimeters not
more than that um
500
finish up
fillet
um and then we just fill it with just a
little bit of a radius i'll just give it
like five centimeter radius just so that
it's nicer
like that that
that
that yeah i'll just take this thing then
and move it from the center point here
to the
from the middle point there to the
middle point there and move it inwards
into the cabinet by
50 centimeters something like that or 50
millimeters sorry something like that so
that you have a little bit of
area to to place your stuff in
in here i need a tab so i'll just borrow
the tap from here
copy
[Music]
move it here of course it needs to be
rotated so i'll rotate it
that
actually find the way it is but i like
to have them off center
like that
trim
[Music]
from that away i'll create a circle here
around this midpoint
the size doesn't matter
like that that's our sink right nothing
nothing more than that
then this is just a cutting area so we
don't need to do anything with it and
this is our cooking area cooking stove
so cooking stove is basically
um it just has four
uh heater blocks right so what i'm going
to do is i'll just
be a little bit cheeky and i'll separate
all of this into four
four segments and then for each of these
four segments i will just create this
kind of a diagonal line
and you'll understand why i'm doing this
in just a second
so i have these diagonal lines here um
each of them have a center point right
and i can use those center points to
show
you know to use as as
center points for my circles which will
show the heater blocks for the stove
right so
usually you have two that are in say the
same size so i'll just use 70
millimeters for this one
70 millimeters for this one then you
have one pretty large one
uh so this one let's say is going to be
a hundred millimeters and you have one a
pretty like pretty small uh let's do 15.
50 millimeters now i don't need anything
else
i just have those those four heater
blocks uh looks bad
why does it look bad that's because it's
too close to the to the edge here but
well maybe we can just do this and no
one will know
that's better okay
that's it that's it with the kitchen uh
i will want to draw a cabinet above
above
the or maybe i don't want a cabinet
i need to fix one thing the refrigerator
is high right
and the window is going to be behind the
refrigerator so this is a bad design
right so i'm going to re remake this
this whole area right here
um that's my bed sorry about that so
actually this this wall right here it
needs to extend until the end of the
refrigerator so i'm going to
how do we do this well let's let's first
create that that wall segment here
or rather first let's
yeah
let's create the wall segment here
like that
perfect now let's actually select the
blue uh
blue windowsill line
and
move its points from here
to here you can also do trimming and so
on but just moving those points around
this is fine
so we do that then we
then we trim
[Music]
enter enter we trim away this area right
here
like so
and we join everything back up so this
is joined
that's clean that is also clean okay so
now i will take the frame copy
from here
to here how wide is it
from here to here we have uh one point
almost two meters that's still too wide
so i'm going to
oh
it's not that wide but no i'll still add
a division here
so if it's
actually i'll show you another way of
how to do this if you just draw a line
segment here and you use the midpoint of
that line as your helper
copy
from the midpoint here
to the midpoint here and then delete the
helper you don't really need to do any
maths it's right in the middle
that's kind of useful
um actually i'll just draw out the lines
in one layer and then just switch the
switch the layers around of already
existing lines
oh man the sun is shining
that's not you usually you need to do
this that's not usual in sweden
i assume we will get like two weeks of
rain now because of this displeasure
that we have
of the two days of sun
okay
so we're back on track right we we have
this we have this done
all right all right all right all right
what's next
i will add a cabinet above
like near the ceiling but i will do that
later
not now
let's solve this and then we'll move on
to
to creating the section
so this
we have our table
right that's just a table we don't
really need to add anything to it if you
want you can add a monitor or
you can add some books and whatnot you
know you can make it more lively but
it's just a table so that's fine and we
have a bed so for the table i need a
chair so i'll just kind of create a
circle that's uh let's go for
um
radius of a chair
radius of a chair let's say
um
20 centimeters
so 40
40 centimeters in time no that's that's
too too little
circle let's let's do 50. so 25
centimeters in radius
something like that and my chair is
going to
let's say it has a bag brace that is an
arc so i will just offset
it inwards by five centimeters
i'll just grab the
i'll just create a two line tools here
or two lines here to both sides
um and then i'll just go to town
trimming everything that i don't need so
i trim enter enter i don't need this
this this or that
that's it um
this whole thing gets joined
so now it's it's a
single pole line and this is another a
line
or rather a circle so here
this guy right here is going to be
medium this guy right here is going to
be thin and the chair is going to be
what i like to do is i like to rotate
um
rotate the the chair just a tiny bit
that's not a tiny bit so let me rotate
it back
just a tiny bit to make it more lively
and place it underneath
the table slightly
right
trim away with the table there we go
uh just so that it's you know
under the table and and you can see that
it's it's actually a chair
um
so that is that now for the bed
the bed the bed the bed um
we really need just pillows and and the
bed sheets right to show this as a bed
so that's not going to be tricky
i'm going to just grab a
rectangle tool
and i'll just make
two random rectangles for the pillows
they pillows are not that accurate so i
can kind of get away in making weird
ones
um
just for
reference i'll measure the distance
that's 300 millimeters so i will fill
that
all of the pillows by
[Music]
130 millimeters or 140 millimeters right
so all of the corners get related
wait that's
again
the let
r enter 140 enter
ah there we go now it works okay
so just fill it let it fill it
uh
right now i should probably i forgot to
mention one thing there's one more
snapping option that that you can
accidentally enable and that's called
grid snapping
which i believe is
yeah
it's right here snapping mode grid
if you have this turned on
then your cursor or when when you're
trying to draw something
it's going to snap
to the grid lines
like so
that is obnoxious and i absolutely hate
that so just make sure that grid
snapping right here in the bottom is
turned off right just
just a tip
okay so we have two
weird pillows here one large one one one
smaller one that's that's fine i can
actually place them together and
trim
the let's see the large one with the
small one like that
go away
like that i will make them
pin
like so so those are two two pillows and
let me just position them
a little bit more centered
like so
uh then we have a bed sheet that will
go over the pillows
so it just kind of
goes over them like so
right and it trims
away of the pillows
that is the bed sheet and the bed sheet
uh usually the the way i i personally
prefer doing it is it it has this kind
of a
hold
here
right
so it's it's
folded folded out
that's it that's that's the bed with two
pillows kind of tucked away be behind
the bed sheet
all right we have this uh this plan
then the plan
let's move on to creating a section
so
or or no sorry well maybe
apologies just a second
i'm gonna think
can we move into section making
yeah let's move into section making so
the first thing that we want to do is we
want to mark out where we're going to
cut the building through right with
what's the cutting line so i'm just
going to create a straight line segment
like that and i'm just going to see
where with the move tool where i can
position it so that it cuts and shows
the most things so my thoughts are
and usually you don't want to cut
through the
furniture
you either show the furniture in the
projection of the cut or you
or you don't
right but you don't cut through the
furniture in this case we are going to
be cutting through the sink but that is
fine
if you are cutting through furniture you
you're not hatching it in so you're not
filling in the cut
that is important
to note
you're just showing it as if it's in the
projection
um let's do that i think we can do that
because
we will see quite quite a bit
and my viewing direction is going to be
that away
right so i'm going to see
uh
i'm going to be cutting through the
window through the sink through the door
through another door
through another window i'm going to be
seeing the door the side of the the
cabinet
here the or the side of the shelf here
the
[Music]
kitchen
area kitchen front i'll see uh
side of the window
and um
and the toilet what i won't see is the
shower the bedroom uh or the the bed and
the work table which is fine
it's
you know you can't
add everything to a single section
usually you need to do more than one
section to show everything in the
building
that's fine um so the way i really like
doing this is
first i will go to layer properties
here and i'll just create a new layer
and i'll call it helper
helper layer and it can be white that's
fine just
a single additional layer i'll make it
my active layer so that's my helper and
what i want to do is basically make a
cut here so i need to
to have all of the
correct dimensions so my workflow and it
might be
i think it's it's a workflow of everyone
who uses autocad is just dragging out
just dragging out
the the lines or maybe i should should
draw it from here just so that it's it's
clear more clear for you
dragging out
the main lines
that that i wanna
i wanna keep working with right that i
will see in this section
so that
that can come in later well no
let's let's do it now
like that
then this is gonna be a line
this doesn't necessarily need to be a
line but i will
i'll add it
um then we have the whole kitchen area
so
this edge right here is going to be a
line
and then we will have the last
line here so we have a bunch of like
vertical lines extended there's like uh
that
i forgot the name of it
just a second
how is it called um
construction line
i think it's construction line
yeah so there is one more uh tool that
can be used and it's called construction
line so
um it's it's located right here
or the shortcut for it is x
line and
the thing about x lines is that they are
infinite in length right
so you can use construction lines but
this is a very simple project so i'm not
i'm not really used using them right in
in this case
so i'm just dragging out regular ones
um right so we have that
and now i i will just start drawing
right so i'll create uh
let's stick to the helper layer for now
uh first thing that i do is i'll just
draw a horizontal line this is going to
be my ground right
this is my ground
line
and basically my building
starts here with this line and ends here
with this line right and i'm taking that
projection and looking at it
all right
so i have that going on
and
now now i can actually start drawing
right so let me go and create a thick
create a thick
line here
and create a polyline
sorry change this to thick layer and
create a polyline
and i'll just draw out
in between the
the walls so this wall right here and
this wall right here in between them
i'll draw out the floor slab so i know
that the floor slab will start from here
will end here its height is going to be
something around
i would say 400 millimeters
something like that or 100
initials up here
bam
that's done that's my floor slab and i
accidentally um
drew it above
the
ground line
right so this is like our ground
uh
ground cut that
where we start cutting through the earth
so this is air this is
this is air this is earth right so i'm
going to just take this and
move it into the ground like that
okay so that is done
now
uh my walls
right i'll just kind of create the the
walls so the question is how high
is the ceiling going to be and what kind
of roof are we going to have
that's that's the main question and i
haven't sketched this out so i have no
idea
um
my thoughts are
let's have an awkward pitched roof
why why the heck not
right let's let's have an awkward
awkward pitched roof
maybe
give me a second and i'm just thinking
um
or
no i will not be making a pitched roof
instead i'll i'll make like a like a
separate some sort of a separated roof
here uh why not so
i need
the height of the ceiling right so i
will offset
i will offset this ground line
uh by
by how much
how much by how much
i can also just copy it up as well
let's say the ceiling height
in my shower is just going to be 2 600
millimeters
2.6 meters
which is probably going to be pretty
high
that's pretty high let's do less
offset 2 400 millimeters
also pretty high
go again offset
2
300 millimeters
i don't want to go lower than that so
okay so that's my ceiling height in this
area and for this area i will want a
higher ceiling height so let's say
offset
three thousand
yeah just let's just do three meters
three thousand millimeters
something like that so that's going to
be the ceiling height in this area right
here
um
i think that's going to work i think
that's
that should work right yeah that should
work
yeah it's gonna work okay
so now um
i have my floor slab
i need to create walls right so i'll
just grab a polyline tool and i will
just start drawing in the walls so
my wall here is going to look like
that
enter
right and my wall here is going to be
larger it's going to look like that
enter
right so i have one wall here one wall
here
and the ground slab here or or the floor
slab here
okay so we have that done
now for the
actual roof slabs
i will create more offsets here bear
with me
offset
and the roof is usually thicker than the
walls
these days the roof is around 700
millimeters thick in
[Music]
you know in buildings
but for this particular summer house i
think we can get away with uh
500 400 millimeters i'll just do 400
well 450 let's let's have the middle
ground here so i will offset it by 450
and i'll offset the ceiling the the high
splint up by 450 and the smaller ceiling
up by 450
like that that's a lot of lines to to
look at now right and you will get used
to it
eventually
um now actually what i can just do is i
can take a rectangle tool
and just draw out
the roof slab
let's see
how far will the lower roof slab reach
probably until here right
and then we will have the the large roof
slab going on here yeah i think that's
that's gonna be
that's gonna be the trick so
i have this line marked out and this is
going to be how far the bottom row slab
reaches so i'm just going to draw out oh
now i forgot
it's this line here so i'm just going to
draw out a rectangle
like so
that's my bottom roof slab
and then for the top roof slab of course
it continues on from where the bottom
row slap ended
you know until here
there we go
so we have
roof roof wall wall
floor
let me delete
all of the horizontal lines
we don't need them anymore we will be
working with vertical lines
but we don't need the horizontal ones
anymore
um right
so we have that going on
now let's
create some foundation foundation blocks
because this is a little bit
a little bit obnoxious right the way
this this connection looks like that's
not a strong connection
um so i'll create a polyline
and i'll just create a block
that how how with how deep is
how deep is the floor
so the floor is 400 millimeters deep so
i'll create a foundation block that is
plus
let's say plus 600 millimeters
so the foundation block is going to be
one meter deep from the
from the wall
right
uh so
polyline going down
1 000 millimeters
finishing up here
connecting as
as a rectangle
same thing here well actually let's just
copy it why not
copy
from here
here so that's the foundation that's
going into the into the ground okay
that is them
now
i kind of want to clean everything up
right so i will hide the helper layer
for for just a tiny bit
i will hide it and i want to join
everything up into one
big happy
family and also one more thing that i
want to do is add a wall segment right
here because these two roofs need to
connect right so i will create a
polyline
from here uh to here
and it's going to be uh
let's do
honestly i would want to do 400
millimeters but in this case let's do
250
50
and how long is it 700 millimeters down
and just close it off like that
okay
so now we have our our shape and
honestly
honestly the way i would do this i could
start trimming and joining but this is
going to be so much faster if i just
uh change this to medium layer
turn on thick layer or change this to
medium layer escape out
and draw redraw everything in thick
layer as a single or as two polylines
like that
so just going around the perimeter
yep messed it up
there we go
and then going around the inner
perimeter
like that
then i just hide the thick layer
i
turn the current layer off whatever
delete the medium layer
and turn the thick layer again
and i messed it up
so there needs to be a line here and it
needs to be joined up there we go you
should see something like this right
so that is
uh the section of your or rather the
exterior envelope of you of this
particular building right that i want i
also will add just so that i don't
forget i will add
ground
here and here that's the ground cut line
and i will actually take this uh this
ground cut line and i will move it down
by five
uh or 50 millimeters just so that the
uh the the floor slab is five
centimeters higher than the ground
uh the reason for that is when it's
raining you don't want the rain to visit
your house
right so
that's the reason that's the reason
also it it's it's good for for kind of
brushing uh the the
dirt out of the building as well
uh as as you leave the to the building
okay
so that's ground that's that's uh
our little building here let's continue
on
so now i want to add partitioning walls
because i can see that
there is going to be a partitioning wall
here
where we will also show that we are
cutting through the
the doorway
and also there is going to be like a
retaining or partitioning wall that we
will just see in the back
right
so we need that as well
let's do that let us
let us do that
so i will go
into my helper
i will enable my helper
layer i'll start drawing some rectangles
wrecked
rectangle
so partitioning wall right here
that
just a rectangle
um then there's no partitioning wall
here but there is going to be a
partition goal here but i accidentally
forgot to add
do we need to add or maybe we can use
this
um
it can be kinda joined up
with the shelf
in a way
yeah let's let's do it uh let's do it
this way i'll just create a one more
helper line from this point here
downwards
uh we'll create a thick line a rectangle
just something like so
like that and i will create a very weird
with a medium line
or rather this sorry sorry sorry sorry
this needs to be a medium line because
we are not cutting through it of course
we are not cutting through it so it is
indeed medium line
thickness
and i will create one more medium line
that shows the
shelf at the at the side
so it's going to look like it is going
to look weird but that is fine
that is okay usually uh you don't have
these kind of weird gaps here but
actually we can kind of since we are
since we are here
and i just kind of
fix it yeah let's fix it
uh so i'll delete the two helper lines
that are for help helper lines that i
don't need anymore
i will kind of add them later on i don't
need these anymore as well actually i
don't need any of these anymore
great we can delete all of them and i
wanna fix this area right here this is
an awkward area
so what i'm gonna do is i will go in
here
oh i know i know uh so
let me just create a line segment here
just so that i don't forget where it
ends
and all i will do is just take these
points and move them to perpendicular
snap
what the hell perpendicular snapping is
turned on why is this not working
fine
fine
we will do it the other way around i
will trim enter enter
delete that segment here
i will extend
this line
to here or
enter
extend
to here
enter this line like that
and then i will create a thick line
segment right here
at
and i will fill that
there we go
uh fill it with radius of zero
so fillet radius zero
from here to here
that is done and now it just needs to be
joined up properly
join
should be good yes it's good so
ah
right and now
just a rectangle
for the shelf
like that
okay so now it's done sorry
i just wanted to clean it up a little
bit
um just to make it a bit a bit nicer
okay so we have that done uh now for the
let's add the doors and the windows into
the walls
right
uh so
let's start with a window opening here
on the left hand side right so my
windowsill is going to be probably
somewhere around
i'll just start drawing here from from
the bottom up it's going to be offset
and i'm going to offset it
uh 1.1 meters 1 1 0 0
something like that
and the height of the window is probably
going to be until the
until the
roof
right so i'm just going to not even
measure but just
draw it like that
that's it
right
i will change this to
the thick layer
select it
get rid of that
join everything up that's done right so
the the
the window opening is done and then it's
absolutely the same procedure as what
we've done in the plan so i will not be
kind of talking about it i'll just
really quickly be
recreating it
i'll actually even make a shortcut i'll
just borrow the
existing window
here
like that
there we go
so we have a window here
um
doorway
doorway is very simple all we need to do
is just
well we need to know how high the
doorway is and it it is a
2
meter 2.1 meters
high
that's
that's almost nothing
that's almost nothing okay and i will
just trim
[Music]
uh
trim enter
trim away everything except for
except for the
top
you know this little area right here and
actually i want to
join it in with the with the roof
so i will
trim enter
like that
join everything up
uh it gets joined up into the incorrect
layer so i'll just switch the layers
around like that
um now let's go for the thick line
because we are going to be cutting
through the doors and just add a door
segment here
um honestly
let's make it a little bit nicer i'll
just borrow the
the frame we will just use the same
frame for the door
copy
from here
to here like that
that's that's the frame for the door and
maybe we can make it a little bit nicer
as well yeah let's just make it nice um
so that frame is going to be
all the way through and it's going to be
five centimeters thick and
40 centimeters wide
it's a wide frame right
um and it's going to
have a door
going through from the middle of it like
like that so we are cutting through the
door and we also see the back of the
frame as per usual right so we see
this wall right here in our projection
so that is going to be a medium line and
it's going to be a rectangle
like so i can't draw a rectangle
properly let me just draw a pole line
then instead 140 millimeters with
there we go
so that's our door doorway right
and that's done now to show a doorway in
the
in the projection
i already have the 2.1 meter height here
so i don't really need to invent
anything and i know that this doorway is
90 centimeters wide
so i don't really need to and make any
calculations i can just do
this
900
bam
bam
bam
like that um and then
then i kind of want to
i don't really need the bottom line do i
okay let me
explode
so i explode this fall line i will
delete the bottom line
i will take this
this line segments that are left again
it's upside down u now i will join them
up
perfect and i will i will offset
all of this by 50
millimeters
inwards
so that's our frame for the door and for
the handle i will just
where's that water
tap i'll just use the handle here
doesn't need to be precise just
something like that
so that's that's the handle
um and that's honestly that's honestly
it in terms of the doorway that's our
shelf
that's good that's our wall
it's also good then we have the kitchen
kitchen cabinet and we have another
really large window here so for this
window i know that here i'll have a
kitchen cabinet and the kitchen cabinet
is always 1.1 meters high uh so
this window line that i
i drew here kind of continues on right
and the first thing that i'm going to do
is i will make
[Music]
i'll probably make something like this
right so the window is going to be
located here and then i have the
possibility to add shelving here in the
top
i think the storage i think that's
that's fine
so
i will
trim
enter
cut away that part right because that's
where the window is going to be located
now i can delete
um and i will
draw
two line segments here
as per usual
join everything up ah
change the layer
change the layer of this one as well
there we go
and honestly i think i can just kind of
cheat
and do this
yes i can okay
so i'll just uh take that window and
place it in there as well
so we have that but also i have the
window
going until
until here
right
because i see i see this with this this
window area here and it's actually not
going until the the wall it's actually
stopping
right here right
uh so i will have
let me draw this u shape here
i will have a window here
like that
which means
that now i don't see this line anymore
because it's a corner window right so i
don't don't have
don't have neither this
nor this line anymore so i can just
delete it
right because i
as i'm looking through this i never see
the you know
here i see the the wall here i won't see
the wall right because i'm looking
through it i'm i'm i have a window that
goes through the whole facade
uh so that's done now i will
offset
50 millimeters
i will offset this by 50 millimeters
like that
and i will actually extend it
just by grabbing the control points
or you can use extend tool that's fine
as well
i'll extend it until this one so this is
the frame that we see right
uh now i can see that there are going to
be divisions here
uh well at least one division here so
i'm just going to kind of draw out those
two lines because i'm lazy
like that
and i'll use trim
enter enter
to kind of clean everything up
so
come on
there we go and then get rid of the rest
but that's that's my window
yeah that that's that's all all i need
to show
um now for the kitchen cabinets uh
and actually maybe i want no i'll i'll
stick to this for the kitchen cabinets
it's going to be uh just a polyline and
just
a rectangle
or maybe we can do
let's do let's do it this way
from here to here
600 millimeters
down here
um
so that is like one
one block
copy that
that that is my kitchen and
my refrigerator is actually going to be
larger than that so i will
i will say that my refrigerator is an
arrow boy that just kind of fits in
there
like this
right um now for the top shelving i
actually kind of want to have
shelves in the top so i'm just going to
say
um
there's gonna be
like a
single cabinet here and then there is
going to be like open shelving here so
i'll just offset it inwards by 50
millimeters
so that is open shelving and this is
like closed cabinet shelving to which i
can add
a handle
like that
all right um
we can do uh a wire tap as well
uh wait where is our water there we go
this it's uh
that it's it's there right so i will
just kind of
create
a
a a circle
trim
trim
enter
bam do something like that uh create a
poll line
that does something like
that
offset
20
offset it so that it's like or rather
let's first
fill it
uh
let
also 20
millimeters
why this fillet oh right flat enter air
r
enter
let's not use 20 let's use 50
millimeters
in here and here
like this and now i can offset
uh by 20 millimeters
outwards like that
just kind of close off the pole line
like so
join everything up and now do a little
bit of trimming so trim
that
and that
then line
um
go lower
trim
come on trim
enter
there we go and you need to be
also
trimmed yeah
uh so just you know awkward water tap
with some big
really big knob
whatever
okay so we have that that going on and
that is fine
that that looks okay
and there is still sync and toilet that
are left to do so i'll really quickly do
it so for the sink i'm i'm thinking of
having something like this
um
how wide is the sink i believe we used
400 right so it's going to be 400 mil
here then it goes down by
let's say
100 mil
something like that
and then it goes at an angle
and that angle doesn't really matter
right now so i'm just going to say
something like that
right that's it uh fill that
uh flat corner or or just fill it
radius
uh
30
just let those
radii
like that that's our sink where is my
trusty
app
right there
i'll just
kinda rearrange the rearrange it scale
this bad boy 0.5
move
to here
and this
trim this trims away
tap
good so that's our sink and then we have
the last thing as our bowl and i will
just take a look at the bowl how it
looks like from the front
uh that's ugly
like a nicer one
yeah that's good enough so it just goes
kind of straight down well it does make
a bend and it goes in a little bit um
that's fine uh let's do it that way so
i will create two guidelines
here oh that's not uh how you want to do
it
guideline here guideline here how high
are the bowls as well
um 450.
so they are 450 millimeters high that's
that's good to know where's my autocad
um
[Music]
how do we do this so
there's going to be a line here it needs
to go down and in okay so let's do an
offset by how much it's going to kind of
go in let's see by five centimeters
like that like that
now let's draw a line at the bottom at
the base and let's offset it
by 450 millimeters that's the top of the
ball and let's offset it down by
uh i don't know 150 millimeters
this is uh from where it's going to kind
of become
thinner and now i just need to trace
around so from here to here to here
here
here
until here
enter
delete all of the
guide
lines
like that that's our bowl
yeah the proportion is fine i'll keep it
that that's all we need to do and the
flush
the flesh button is located here uh now
for the storage uh there is going to be
um i i have made that that that cabinet
in in the back of the bathroom so there
is going to be storage involved here uh
so i'll just draw a polyline from let's
see the storage starts at the sink level
so from here upwards um
let's say for the toilet rolls
the all of the
you know
[Music]
stuff that you need at hand uh
let's just give give it
300 millimeters
something like that
so this is going to be
like open storage
right this area so i'll just give it a
frame of 50 millimeters
just to show the frame oh that's uh 50
is too much
maybe let's not give it no i will give
it a frame
uh offset uh 18 millimeters that's the
thickness of an mdf board
uh like that we need to clean this up a
bit
trim
[Music]
no no
there we go
so that's storage and then above it we
will have like three panels
um i think we will have three panels
let's do three panels so from this side
we will offset
um
by how much by how much by how much
if that's a meter then we can do
300 300 400 i think that's that's
reasonable so let's do an offset
of
300.
centimeters or millimeters offset by 400
millimeters
something like that
so that is kind of storage above the
above the toilet
done but
that's enough that's enough i think we
have the door we have the door we have
the shelf here we have the retaining
wall we have the partitioning wall
window everything that we see here
everything that we see here okay section
is done
let's learn one last thing and then we
will call it a day
so one last thing is hatch
and by the way um
for this section
let's make the mark out a little bit
nicer as well because it's a little bit
you know
um so let's make the mark out a little
bit nicer
usually
there's no kind of convention for what
kind of section markups to use
the ones that the one that i really like
using is
a line segment that is i don't know uh
in in this case it's going to be like uh
600 millimeters something like that
it's kind of a line segment here
then we have um
then i offset it
and i'll offset it by
300 millimeters
no that is way too much i'm sorry i will
offset it by a hundred millimeters
yeah there we go that's much better and
i will draw
to the midpoint here
this
um this arrow and i'll just join up this
arrow
so now i i have a line and i have an
arrow just like here line and arrow
arrow is showing the viewing direction
for this section and later i will add a
text here or i can add text here now so
the shortcut is text
enter
um you specify the start point here and
you type in or
you you specify the height of the text
so what's the height what's the height
i don't know
[Music]
let's do 200 for now and we will we will
switch switch it up if it's too small so
height is 200 enter
and
rotation angle of text 0 enter
and now i can type in finally so
next text text a
that that's it
escape uh
we just drew we just wrote a
right and i'm just going to kinda center
it
so
one once i name this section it's going
to be named section a dash a or a
is that the dash it's probably a dash a
a section a a
and i will just place that section
markup
right here
make a copy of it
to the other side of the building
very important to have section markups
in your project please do so
um right so that's text right add adding
text that's nothing too fancy it's just
basically you read what it asks you
asks of you in the command line and
you'll be good to go
the text will need a separate layer so
let me go to layer properties and let me
create one more layer
and i'll call it
text
right so that's going to be my text
layer and my text is going to be yellow
sure
and then i'm going to create one more
layer
even more layers yes one more layer and
call it hatch
so hatch is basically fill right
in in photoshop in illustrator you have
phil in
[Music]
cad software you have hatch
so hatch layer and i'll make it
red green cn yellow
pink
or magenta all right so let's
have a hatch layer with magenta color
close that
now i will take my markups
and i'll place them in the text layer
like so
and now i will use hatch
right
to fill in the walls
so i'll go to i'll make hatch layer my
active one
and i'll type in
hatch
or shortcut for it is just h
enter so that's hatch
and once i have typed it in it will give
me the settings for the hatch of course
where i can choose different
patterns yes the word is pattern
different patterns right
uh and also like i can change the
transparency the angle and so on so let
me
um let's let's do it this way let me
create a rectangle
like so
and hatch it in
right so
if i just click inside of the rectangle
and hit enter
that's it it's hatched in right
and this is
it even has a pattern if i zoom in
right and the pattern is super dense so
it looks kind of filled in from from
when i am zoomed out
uh so that's a lot of bad things
happening with the hash let me select
the hatch and delete it
let me also do
a rectangle that is not closed
right
there's a gap here
hatch
click cannot be
determined right can a hatch cannot be
made close
shows me even where
so it only works with stuff that is
closed off right
uh can you go away please
oh my god now now i'm gonna
anyway let's ignore those two circles
here um so it only works with enclosed
uh boundaries uh that's the first thing
the second thing it uh
the scaling is very important and it it
does become super heavy if you have a
pattern for the hatch but your
scaling is so small
that it looks like a solid and you think
that you have a solid hash like a solid
fill but it's actually a very very tiny
pattern your computer will get super
slow because of that
so let me do hatch again
and here i can choose a pattern right so
the solid patterns just basically fill
in right it's just filling in then you
have the angled patterns and you have a
bunch of them actually is it possible
for me yeah so i can click on that small
icon there and i can see all of the
patterns that i can choose from
oh my god so
so bad um
so let's not look at the bad patterns
let's just talk about these what you
have here so hatch patterns usually
determine the material that you're
cutting through and if it's a solid
hatch it's usually you saying that
don't worry about the material for now
this is just a proposal entry uh project
and the material doesn't matter right
but if you
later
layer down the line if you want to kind
of add materiality to your drawings
explaining that oh this is concrete
while this is wood while this is steel
then you use hatches different hatches
that determine it so
the regular angled hatch
this one where i have my mouse
is
concrete usually
right it's concrete
then the one
right next to it the one with the double
line
uh
well okay
the tricky thing is that it changes
between country to country right the the
regulations uh change between country to
country but
to my knowledge most of the countries
use this as steel
metal right so that's the hatch for
metal
and the third one is hatch for wood
right
so that is uh three main hatches that
you
kind of go through once you introduce
materiality for now i'm just going to
use solid hatch well actually i do need
to talk about scaling solid hatch
doesn't have any scaling because it's
solid right it's filled in while these
do
so you can change the density of the
hatch
so let's let's talk about this let's
let's choose concrete right the the
regular angled hedge
once i have this chosen
and i hover my mouse over the rectangle
i
see it as solid but if i zoom in
it is still solid no it's not
there we go it's it's all messed up
right it's it's super super dense so the
first thing that i want to do is i want
to change the density and the density is
changed right here
patch pattern scale right if i change
the scale to 100
enter
and i hover my mouse over the rectangle
now you can see that the hatch has a
hundred times larger scale and that is
actually too big
so let's do 50.
yeah that's fine um just to show you you
know so that's 50.
then you have uh
possibility to change the angle so this
is uh
you know the default hatch what if i
wanted just horizontal well i just
changed the angle to 45
well that's vertical but you get the
idea right so
minus 45 would be
horizontal
right
so that is how you change the rotation
of the hatch uh super useful uh for now
i will keep it at zero and the default
value for the hash is zero degrees then
you have transparency don't mess around
with transparency ignore the
transparency
uh there's one more thing and that is uh
one more
useful thing and that is set origin
and it's basically if i
let me just create this hatch and then
click on it once once once it's created
and i click on it it will
give me the hash editor tab again right
as if i was editing it
and now i can change the origin right so
this is a point
from which the from which
autocad starts hatching your geometry
right so if i click on this set origin
now and i choose let's say
this point right here right
the hatch will be aligned with that
particular point so when you need
something precise in terms of how it's
hatched that set origin point is a
lifesaver for sure
that's about it in terms of hatching so
now let's hatch our
our buildings
catch
enter
i will actually use the angled hatch why
not
and i will just be
clicking inside
of
the
walls
because that's the stuff that we cut
through right
uh i could be hatching inside of the
frames window frames but that's not no
way too small no need to hatch those
uh so that's that's the walls that are
done enter
and actually the hatch is pretty big
pretty coarse so what i can do is i can
just select it
go back here
to hatch editor and then just change the
the density to like 20 maybe yeah 20 is
nicer that is now hatch then and let's
do the same thing with the ground
because i want the ground to be hatched
in as well uh so i'm just going to
create a temporary polyline here
maybe
a little bit
smaller
maybe just goes
from here to here
something like
that
maybe a little bit longer there this is
just uh
you don't need
you don't need to be precise with this
um
just hatching out the hatching in the
ground so it's something like this and
then i will
start from
my pole line start there
just make a horizontal line and just use
fillet
with radius of zero
to kind of let these two guys together
so now i have a closed ball line and i
will hatch
and i will place a hatch inside and i
will change change it to a different
kind of a
different kind of a pattern
i'm just thinking what kind of pattern
should i use maybe i'll still use the
angled one but i will change the angle
to 45 degrees
something like that and i will change
the density to
30
something like that
that should be good enough
and now i don't need that border anymore
so i'll just delete it just to have the
hatch right
okay
i think that is that is it
can i check
i will just check the notes
uh just give me a second
[Music]
array uh next time
arrays whatever uh not important
text oh i already showed you text that's
good uh less things to show you tomorrow
um
that's fine
yeah uh so so that's good uh everything
that i wanted to show today is shown
tomorrow we will work on the axonometry
and we will finish up the project right
so that's that
go to work
and enjoy the process
there
bye
hello hello
and welcome to the last part of the
autocad series
where i'm going to
and finish up this project and show you
all of the remaining tools that we kind
of need to use to be able to finish up
so right now we have a plan we have a
section
those still need some some work and
those stills need some additional
information but most of the stuff that
we want is already there
the thing that's missing
is the axonometry drawing so i'm going
to do exactly that right now and then we
will continue on with adding additional
information and
basically extracting the drawings into a
pdf
so
to start off um axonometry or
isometric view is basically a view from
the
top
sometimes it's from three quarters of
the top but
uh in this case we're just going to be
using some
weird angles i guess and a very fast
example would be if i have a rectangle
and i'll just draw it completely
randomly
just some sort of random sized rectangle
and let me switch to thick line
just so that
we're kind of consistent
um let's see this rectangle represents
the top of our
shape of our box right so if we look at
the box from the top it's a rectangle
right so what if i want to show an
isonometric view of it well first thing
that i do is i check
uh what kind of angles i can use so i
can use 45 to 45 degree angles for the
walls or i can use 60 to 30 degrees
that's that's usually the
typically that's the angles that you use
so i will show you both of them in
uh
yeah i'll just show you both of those
variations
so
basically for 45 degree angles you can't
really do
like drawing them with uh
without any
assistance is kind of tricky well it's
not tricky it's just that you first need
to draw it horizontally right some sort
of line and then you need to rotate it
every time
by minus 45
well that's the other way around but but
you get what i mean you know to get a 45
degree angle you just kind of draw the
line horizontally and you rotate it
that's not nice instead what we can do
is we can use this polar
uh tracking
widget right here
in the bottom
it's f10 the shortcut is f10
so i will enable it by clicking on it
and also we can expand it and we can see
so you can expand it by clicking this
small
triangular icon right here and once you
expand it you can see the angles that
it's going to
let you choose right so it's basically
in increments so you can have like 90
degree uh increments you can have 45
degree increments 30 degree increments
25.5 degree increments and so on so
for
an axo that is 45 to 45 degrees i can
use this 45 degree increment
um
color tracking is it called yeah polar
tracking
so i will enable that so now this is
tick marked
and now when i draw a line
it snaps
to a direction of 45 degrees which is
great so now let's draw uh this this box
uh
in an axle to do that i need to know
these two measurements so i'll just
measure distance
this
like that and it's around uh
i drew the box very
randomly so
i will just say that it's around six ten
six thousand millimeters right so then i
just grab a polyline or a line tool
doesn't matter i'll just draw it at 45
degree angles
as 6000 enter
so that's my line right
then i will measure the other wall
like so
and i see that it's
3251. so let's say
3250 millimeters
i'll grab a polyline tool again
i'll just draw it out yeah like so
3 500
3250 right enter
that's it we have the two lines and that
these two lines are going to be enough
for me to finish up
drawing this this particular
this particular box
because now what i can do is i can copy
this line
from from its base point here to the
base point here and i can you can see
that i missed so i'll do that again
select it copy
from here
to
here
there we go that's much better and then
i will
i will select the
other line copy
from its base point here
to the base point here
that's about it right now now we have
our
um
45
degree angle axle off the
top of the box but of course in an
axonometry you can see it as a
three-dimensional um three-dimensional
object so let's see the
height of this box is three meters three
thousand millimeters so what i like
doing is i like selecting the let's say
this is the roof right i like selecting
the roof plane
and copying it copy
and i'll just copy it from top to bottom
like so and i'll just type in 3 000
millimeters
right and hit escape so then i have the
bottom of the box as well now all i need
to do is just some additional lines for
verticals
and clean it up right so i'll just draw
those slides
like so
like so
and like so and then trim
enter enter
and get rid of everything that we
don't need don't need that
don't need that that's it
that's the 45 degree
axle right
30 60 degree axle
uh or iso view would look like this well
first of all i need to
change the polar snapping polar tracking
to
30 degree increments of course
and then i kind of do the same thing so
i remember that this is 60
or
60. this is 6 000
millimeters and this is 3250 millimeters
so let me do this um
i will find
a 30 degree angle right here and i'll
say 6 000
like so
i will
then find the 60 degree angle here and i
i'll say 3250
like so
and actually i can kind of continue
drawing it this way or yeah let's let's
stick to it i'll i'll copy
right so the procedure is exactly the
same
copy
like that
it the height doesn't change of course
3000
like that
accidentally moved it i guess in the
incorrect way
copy
please move downwards 3000 enter
yeah now it's good
three lines
bam
bam
bam
those three lines are done and now
or
just trim enter enter
get rid of that
get rid of that
and delete those two
there we go so that's a 30 60 degree
angle right
very simple let's do this with our
with our building
um
so i will say that i wanna
i wanna kind of look at it
maybe from this point on i don't know
well if we look at it from this point on
it's it's going to be the
the large roof and then the small roof
maybe that's fine
or maybe we can yeah let's look at it
actually from
[Music]
from here from this point right
like so
so i will
measure
distance
and i'll do it 30 60. i'll measure
distance so that's 6 000 millimeters in
length
and of course the width is going to be 4
000 millimeters
like that or thousand
so
i will just grab a polyline tool and
just draw it out like so
and i'll see
6 000
in this length
there we
go
4000
along this line
so
make a copy
bam
and make
and and then basically close it off
right so let's say this is like the
footprint of of my building right so
this is
uh this edge right here around my
building then i need to know the height
uh the height of it and here i kind of
have um
how do we do this
yeah let's uh draw it from the ground
yeah that makes sense
so i'll i'll do distance
sorry about this um i do want to
actually
select this
join this up
right and i want to first take the floor
slab and move it up to the correct
height
right
just like i did with the box
in the case of the box i moved it down
in this case i'm moving it up it's the
same procedure basically so i'll just
measure distance
uh from here
to the top here and i can see the
distance is 3500 right so i'll just take
this copy
up
3500
like that
and then
i'm going to measure distance here
distance
from here to here
that is two thousand eight hundred right
so i'm just going to make another copy
up
two thousand two thousand eight hundred
there we go right so now i have all of
the levels that i that i will need for
my axle and i can start connecting them
um before i begin
that hiccup right here i need to know
where that hiccup happens right the
change in the height so i'll measure
distance again
from here to here 2560.
okay
sure so along this line
if i grab a polyline tool along this
line is going to be 2
560
millimeters
enter
and actually let me extend it so i just
have this polyline as a helper and i
know that this point oh
messed it up
let's do this again two five six zero
right or two six five zero oh my god uh
distance
two five six zero okay
from here
to here two five six zero
uh come on
come on just
two five six zero enter
did you snap properly this time yes you
did okay good
always double double check if it's if if
it is snapping properly
so i have that point here and now i can
just draw that point up
draw a line from that point up
the height of the line doesn't matter
because i can just always
select things that i don't need so for
instance i don't need this anymore and i
can delete it and i can also trim enter
enter and trim away the excess right
so i have basically what i've done is i
created this hiccup line right here and
i know that with this hiccup line the
top of the roof ends that the highest
roof it ends so i'll just grab a
polyline tool and i'll just draw it out
like so
or i could just take this line and copy
it
that that works as well
okay so now it
it doesn't look like much but once i
start cleaning it up
it will start taking shape so i'll do
exactly that i'll trim and i'll trim
away
um enter
this area right here
is this
this
and also this
right
so that now is the top of my uh the top
of my roof
and that is the bottom of my roof
and i can basically connect everything
with vertical lines so there's going to
be a vertical line here
there's going to be a vertical line here
and the vertical line here that's that's
all i need to do and now it's just uh
cleaning it cleaning everything up right
so trim again enter enter and get rid of
all of the necessary bits
construction workers
behind the
glass hope you don't hear them
let's do that
all of the unnecessary bits and pieces
that we don't need we just trim away and
i can see that i can just delete that
zigzag here so i'll just kind of delete
it
right
so that's the shape that's the shape of
of
the beautiful building
right
wonderful
um let's continue
so what i want to add now is this
well that's actually a very boring
facade
let me do this real fast
let's grab a grab
this copy
rotate
come on
rotate
and just
create some sort of opening at least
right right
somewhere here and then of course i need
to clean this up so i'm just going to
make
i'm just going to hide the medium lines
for now or rather first i'll create two
thick lines here
here and here
um
[Music]
turn
off the medium layer select these two
lines trim
lead delete
join everything up here and also join
this
join
okay this is closed this is closed
perfect
okay so now we can
we can actually
turn on the medium layer and now we have
additional window here which will not
show up in the section but we we don't
care
um
i deleted the hatch so i'll reinstate
the hatch
hatch
um that's going to be that pattern the i
believe i used 20 for the scale
yeah looks like it i'll just click
inside of the walls where i want the
hatch to be
there we go that is done
enter
okay so we do have a window here now so
it's not going to be that boring at
least
i kind of want to now
cut a hole out for this window and also
of course for this window so the first
thing is i
need to
know what's the height at which the
windows are going to be located and
actually both of their height is going
to be the same it's going to be
one one five zero millimeters above
the ground line this this line right
here so i'm just going to take this
polyline
i'll copy it
up
by one one five zero enter
okay so that is the bottom of the window
and at top of the window i can just
measure the distance again
so my window height is 1.2 meters
so i'll just take this line again copy
up
one two zero zero enter
right that's the top of my of my windows
now i need to know where this edge is
and also where this edge is right so
i'll just measure distance
from the
end of the wall
one five four zero
and then it's going to be another
one of nine nine hundred one five four
zero nine hundred okay
let's do it this way a line along this
line
to make sure that you're just drawing a
polyline in in that
particular direction
and one five four zero
we're doing one five four zero here and
just
honestly just drag it out
you know
so so basically we have this kind of l
shape i i like using it this way
um as as my helper lines actually i
should probably
like have these lines just to be more
pedagogical in the helper
layer because these are just my
helper lines and i'll make my helper
layer active as well
we continue
i just grab this uh i start drawing from
this point along this direction
and i will say 900 because that's the
width of my window
like so
right
like so so this rectangle right here is
where my window is going to be located
in the axle same thing for here but for
here it's going to be quite simple i
just measure the distance
from here to here that's 400 of course
and i can just take this
vertical line here and just make a copy
of it
along this edge so i'll just snap
somewhere to this edge and type in 400
and that makes it into
makes it into a copy
okay let's uh
clean this up again right so
i will just grab the thick line tool and
i'll just grab a polyline tool and here
uh
just make sure that intersection
snapping is turned on
intersection that it's turned on and i
will
and i will just draw out this
twisted rectangle here or project that
rectangle here
that's the hole for my window and i'll
do the same thing here only that it's a
corner window so it's going to be a u
shape rather than a rectangle
like that this
right and now i don't need the helper
lines anymore so i just delete them
there we go
this line right here uh line segment
right here is not necessary so i'll just
trim enter enter
and trim it away
okay
so now to be
pedagogical
i need to give thickness to this right
of course i i need to give
oh
by the way if you do this
accidentally like if you accidentally
rotate the
view just click on the
top
top right
corner box right here and then click on
the arrow keys like here to rotate it
back so that stop is
you know
where you want it to be
um right
continuing on thickness so
to give it thickness all i need to do is
just draw out a line segment here of
course and as you can see i always
tend to draw out line segments that are
too thick and then i just simply trim it
trim them back to to the thickness that
i want
right
um and the thickness of the wall is 400
millimeters i don't even need to check
that so i know that this line will go in
by
400
well actually what we can do
now let's do it the old-fashioned way
um
copy or offset offset would work as well
offset 400
from here to here that's 400 and then
draw just a line segment here
offset that line segment
by 400
and words like so
and delete the original of course
um
trimming again
enter
there we go there we go there we go
okay so that is thickness of the wall
uh here and there's also going to be
thickness of the wall here but
in in this case i'm going to be a little
i keep
holding down the shift key sorry about
that
um
don't hold the shift key as you're
scrolling it's going to rotate the view
uh so in this case i'm just going to
grab a polyline tool draw this l shape
right here
take that l shape and move it
along
along the 30 degree direction right
by 400 millimeters
like so
trim enter enter
trim away
the excess
grab the polyline tool
extend it you have your opening here
right
okay so there's no windows
uh let's add windows of course so the
windows are gonna
keep doing it
um the windows are going to be
located
let's see in the middle or or actually
do i want them in the middle
maybe i do
let's say the windows are going to be
located kinda in the middle of the
of the wall right so i'm just going to
take
um
this polyline that i already have and
i'll copy it from this corner
to the middle corner here and that is
going to be my initial
window
or window plane right
then i will offset
by 50 because i remember that my
thickness of the window frame is 50
millimeters
offset it like
offset it by 50
and just
copy it inwards
by
i don't know
25
25
something like that and now it's just a
bunch of cleaning up right so the more
curves you have the
more you need to think what you're
cleaning
uh but it's basically going to be if i
trim
enter of course i don't see anything
that's going on here
that's gone
um i will not through the window
technically you since it's glass you
would see that the back side of the wall
but in this case we don't want to show
it so i'm not going to be showing it
and that is basically it
then i just delete the access
and then we have
wall
window frame
and glass
right
so we have our window here same thing
for this
uh same thing for this bad boy right
here
why am i doing this i think this is
because in rhino the the shortcut is
holding down the shift key to pan the
view
so i think that's why i'm doing it
anyway
um
in this case it's exactly exactly the
same procedure
only that i'm going to
draw a polyline
like so
let me make it make it white uh helper
line
layer so i'll just
draw it as a white pollen so that it's
easier for you to see
make a polyline
pop it in
and i will just make a copy of it or
rather i can just move it actually move
it
inside
of the hole
by
uh
so that's going to be middle of the wall
that will need to be 400
um
no
the wall thickness is 400 so that's
going to be 200 millimeters
something like that so now it's moved in
and of course it makes a bend here right
so i can't have that line
just located here it needs to go in
and
the way is going to go in like the way
i'm going to find that point uh by how
much this edge needs to go in
i'm talking about
this corner and this frame right here
see how it's it's going in it's not you
know resting on the side of the wall uh
same thing here it can't rest on this
side of the wall it needs to go in so i
am going to just grab this
line
right here and i will make an offset of
it by 200
inwards so now i can see
the
the new
um
the new line segment
that i can draw and i'll draw it of
course
so helper apollo line
from here
upwards
it's like that
we need to clean it up
because the more again the more curves
you have the
uh the harder it is for you to
understand what the hell is going on
so i'm going to delete all of the
unnecessary bits
um and i'm
going to rotate the view as per usual
i'm going to
trim enter
enter and i'm going to trim away the
things that i don't need so that
and i'm going to join
things that i do need
a second
yeah
um
right so so now i have it offsetted
offsetted uh by 200 inwards and that is
great it makes a bend but we will never
see that bend that it makes so we are
just dealing with this plane here
i will offset it now i'm just doing the
same thing as i'm i was doing here
offset 50
hello
oh
offset 50
there we go
you go in
then take this
copy
along this direction
by 25
and then just draw that small little
line right there for the frame
um
right
now we
clean everything up as per usual trim
trim
bam bam
um
no need for that delete
okay
so that's oh uh
forgot that part
trim
bam bam
now that's fine okay um so i have this
done there's also uh i forgot one thing
we have two partitions
that's oops
that's my bad
so the way i'm going to do partitions i
think
is do we measure from the side of the
wall yeah maybe maybe we just measure
from the side of the wall right
or is that a stupid way to do it
maybe it is a stupid way to do it
i know
let's do it this way i'll draw two
helper lines here
right here
and right here and i will measure their
distances
from this corner from where the window
starts distance to this line
is going to be
1100
and then another distance is going to be
3275
one one zero zero two two seven five
okay i just need to
i am sure that i will forget that
uh so then what i can do is i can just
draw a polyline from here
like so
um
1 1 0 0
like that so that's a point
right here
and let me actually mark it out just
with a random line here
and then another one is going to be
uh
yep forgot it two two seven five there
we go
two two seven five
enter
so it goes until here and i'll just draw
it out like so so i have like these two
two corner points and i know that if i
were to make like an extension for the
frame it would reach those two corner
points so i can kind of backtrack right
i can kind of do this i can grab a
polyline
and i can draw it
like so
please stop
stop rotating
okay follow line like so
and another one like so
right so so now i have anchored my my
lines properly and now all i need to
deal with is just vertical lines right
so i'll just grab a polyline again and
i'll just draw out
i just need to make sure that i'm
sticking to the correct position yeah
there we go i'll just draw draw out
vertical polylines here or vertical line
segments and here
right
now i don't need those helpers anymore
so i'll just delete them so that they're
not in the way anymore
like that
and for these line segments i can
actually
clean them up a little bit more
from come on
trim enter enter
bam bam i can clean them up a little bit
more and i can start messing around with
them so moving them around copy
so you too will be copied enter and you
will be copied along this direction
by 50 millimeters right because that's
that's the thickness of the polar line
right
um or
polyline not the polygon of of the frame
so i i drew this
this line right here and then i copied
it by 50 millimeters
i don't need those helpers anymore
okay so we have that done um and now i
will just take these two line segments
and i will copy them in by
25 millimeters for this thickness right
here only that we will see it on the
side copy
along this direction
25 mil
that's done okay time to clean it up and
make it actually look like a proper
proper window uh trim enter
enter
and now it's just a bunch of trimming
here
so the frame will merge
so the frame kind of does this right it
just merges
um like so and of course you don't see
anything behind the frame
here as well you don't see anything
behind the frame
merges here
um
continues on here like that
okay that's good and let's clean this up
that's good
and there are two line segments that are
missing
where the frame bends like here and also
right here
oh yeah and we don't need to see the
inner line of the wall anymore so we can
just delete that
oh that that as well
that's it that's that is our
window in the axle right
i will change everything to medium layer
uh just because
we are not cutting through anything so
it makes sense that it is a medium layer
except that for the glass i will change
the glass to thin
thin layer because there's too many
too many lines
that are concentrated
uh in in one spot so i don't want them
to merge like graphically i don't want
them to merge into one thick line so i'm
going to make the glass
thin layer
okay
um
now it's all about hatching it right and
making it nicer
um
it's not a very difficult building
that's for sure
um
let me just add the hatch and then we
will continue i don't want to spend too
much time here
so i want to have
planks let's see
horizontal planks going around the
building so i will
go to my hatch layer and i'll create a
hatch
for it
and i'll just
choose let's say this wall enter so i've
just created some random hatch i'll
select it and now we can kind of go to
town here so i know that this is uh
this is 60 degrees this is 30 degrees if
i remember correctly um
so i believe if we do if we do zero
degrees here oh sorry
sorry where when the angle is 0 degrees
it's at 45 right um so let me do or
actually let me change the
yeah i'll use this
instead this hatch instead for the
planks
so instead of 45 we want to first start
with horizontal so let me just say 45
degrees that is not horizontal
so let's add 90 more 135
so now these are horizontal and now i
can kind of rotate them
so i need to rotate it back
so
135 and i rotate it back by 30 degrees
so that's going to be 0 105.
one
105
there we go
and i really want the planks to start
from this point right here so i will
choose it as my as my origin set origin
this point right here so the planks
start from here
okay and now for the scale of the planks
i think the scale is kind of good but
maybe i'll i'll do like 15
something like that
that's it uh now for the other wall same
procedure hatch
selected
angle is not going to to be 105
uh it's actually going to be
[Music]
that's pretty close
my guess is that it's going to be 15
right yeah it's going to be 15.
you can always kind of rotate it with
the slider here and see what kind of
values work or you can do quick math in
your head that that works as well so but
but in this case the angle is 15. i used
scale of 15 as well i believe
and now i need see how these don't match
i need the same origin point so i'll set
origin right here and these don't match
why don't they match
oh right because the angle is different
so of course
sorry
apologies of course they won't match but
also
that's 15 and that is also 15. they look
very very different
both being
both being 15
um
a scale of 15. either way that's good
enough
doesn't matter
okay so we have planks here right we we
have our
our building
um
kind of want to let me just do one thing
offset
uh 250
go in
when
this is uh
you you don't need to do this
this is just me wanting to
and i have
something a little bit more
complex in terms of the room
until here
bear with me
it's not gonna take too long
uh so that's gonna be that that that
that's fine
um can i
go to medium turn off the hatch layer
okay medium is my active turn off the
hatch layer
trim
i'll clean this up a little bit
just a little bit trim
enter
go away
you are correct but you go away
and don't need that anymore don't need
that that
or that
this
is fine
like that
did that
trim again forgot one one part
this
um
what
select
are you locked
haven't accidentally locked it
well that's awkward
oh
undo and do so that was a bug
for that uh i will need to
to fix it
apparently uh that
the screen was frozen for a little bit
and i didn't see that there's there's a
there was a bug
so let's let's clean this up
real fast so that you don't need to wait
too long
no need for that
or that or that
[Music]
ah time when you want to do something
nice you just need to deal with a crap
ton of bugs okay so that's done
this is fine
no need for that this gets extended
you and you get extended
that all is fine and that just needs a
line segment here
okay
a little bit more detail
on on the roof just just to have
something there okay let's let's uh
let's move on uh so we have on our axle
we have our
plan we have our section
if i want to
maybe now it's the time to
uh to create layouts
for for plotting
yeah i think it's it's time
i think it's time
so what we're going to do
sorry
what we're going to do is um
i'm going to explain you what what
layout is first of all i guess um so
this is your model space this is a space
in which you work it's not the space in
which you prepare the
the project to be printed out and where
you work with
additional information
on the project
well adding dimensions will be done here
but everything else will be done
separately in the
layout so a layout is here in the bottom
of this
here in the bottom of the screen you can
see layout uh layout one layout two and
these are of just just there just doing
their thing and we don't really need
them we will be creating our own so i'll
just
delete
okay you just right click on them and
you just delete them
delete
okay
oh this one doesn't delete you need at
least one layout that's fine we will
create our own and we will ignore this
one
so new layout you just click that plus
sign you right click on it
and you choose uh
page setup manager
well first let's rename it i guess
first let's rename it
and let's name it
plan
enter
usually you the convention for naming
them is
zero zero
dash plan
and then zero one dash section zero two
dash axo and so on so that all of them
are kinda laid out properly
but uh in this case we just have three
drawings or whatever all right name name
it whatever you want
so that's our plan
we go to page setup manager we right
click on the layout name we go to page
setup manager
right here
and we modify it
here in the page setup manager you can
see your layout one and the new one that
you've created so you select it and you
click modify
okay so this is where
you kind of set up everything about the
layout uh and
all all of the settings on how what kind
of drawing you want to export right
so
let's start from the
from the start
uh microsoft print to pdf is fine
i prefer using adobe pdf
dwg to pdf is also fine
but anything that can kind of generate
pdf you choose you don't choose a
printer because you will be exporting it
as pdf right so
printing
is not just printing on a sheet of paper
or plotting plotting is the same thing
as printing by the way
it's not printing on a sheet necessarily
on a sheet of paper it can be printing
to a file right so so to a pdf
so in this case i'm going to choose
yeah let's just go with microsoft print
to pdf
if if you
want you can use adobe pdf you can use
dwg to pdf whichever is to pdf you use
uh so that's done let me just hit
properties here and just double check
yeah that's fine that's whatever i'll
keep it with the properties
paper size
here we will find a3
that's the size of the paper that we're
going to be using
uh what to plot layout yes
uh plot offset uh keep it at zero zero
that's fine
scale one two one yes
so here the scale is off the page not of
your model so the scale needs to be one
to one
landscape
yes
and plot
style i use none
for plot style i use none
that's important
that's it
no need for anything
else
yeah no need for anything else
let's just hit ok
hit close and now you can see that the
page became bigger right and this is uh
basically this is like a window uh
showing us our mall and we will position
our our geometry in this
in this page so
how do you do that
well
the thing is first of all you need to
understand the philosophy of layout so a
layout is a
digital a in this case a3 sheet of paper
which has a window in it right it has
like a hole in it and through that hole
you see
you see stuff that you drew in your
model space
right so you see this stuff
in your layout
important note right
uh
that this
rectangle right here
is the frame of that particular hole or
that particular
window
right
so you need that rectangle to be
um first of all properly sized
you know to fill the the
the page and second of all you kind of
want to understand what's the
[Music]
um what's the scale of of
of of these elements because right now
they're just kind of randomly zoomed in
there's no scale right so you want to
have
the scale one more thing that i'm gonna
do
is i am going to
before i kind of continue with the
layouts i'll go to the model space and i
will create some room here and of course
my hatches will not let me so i'll
kind of delete the hatches for a bit
f8
i'll just create a little bit of space
between these
just so that when i grab the view of the
plan it doesn't kind of grab a little
bit of the section i'll create the
sections in the sections the hatch in
just a second for now let's just keep it
and you can see that it by the way
updates here okay
so first thing
is
understanding that this is a page and
this is a window into your model space
and you had a look look at your model
through that window
um
second this is this frame this frame uh
i kind of want it to be
let's go to layer properties i want it
to be in a separate as a separate
entity so i'll create a new layer
i'll call it i'll call this layer
no
print
do not print layer
um and i'll keep it
oh by the way here you can see it says
white
even though it shows black that that is
not a bug that is how it works right so
it will show up white in the model space
but it will be black as it's printed out
just something that just your autocad
things
okay
so
this frame right here i will select it
and i will move it to the no print layer
and the reason why i'm doing this is
because when we are going to be printing
out the layout i don't want this frame
to be visible
by the way those of you are thinking
will the grid be visible no no the grid
will not be visible in the final print
um
but i also don't want the frame to be
visible so that's why i'm putting it in
the separate layer and then we will just
make sure that that layer is not being
printed
during the
printing process
then the next thing is
well let's position this to the center
so i can just kind of move it around
right
f8
i can just move it anywhere i want
i did this window
and now let's make sure
that the scale
or or not the scale that we are focused
on the plan view right in this
particular
uh
in this particular layout so i'm going
to double click inside of it
double click
and now we are not
we can't
move around here
in the layout but rather we are moving
around in the window so when you double
click inside you are
done working
within the window and you can zoom in
zoom out so you can control the
the positioning here right so what i'm
going to do is i will select my plan
and i will type in z
or zoom
and then i will
here in the bottom
i'll choose object
so i've just zoomed in to this object
right
once i've done that
i just double click
anywhere else right not inside
and now
my layout is focused on this particular
or this window this layout window is
focused on this particular drawing
right that's important
i will now need to make sure that the
scale of this drawing in an a3 page is a
correct scale it's 1 to
100 1 to 50 whatever scale i want it to
be right so how do you change the scale
well
for that you will need to access the
properties
of this window frame
so i select this window frame
and i type in pr short for properties
and hit enter
it will open up this page for me
or not page this menu box for me and
i'll position it here
and here in the properties
i can see that there's
under misc
right here there's standard scale and
custom scale so i'll not be using a
custom scale rather i will just expand
the standard skill and i'll find the
scale that i want in this case probably
want to
[Music]
honestly one to 50 is enough
for this kind of a project
like
even one to a hundred would be enough
but that's way too small uh so instead
i'll just use one to fifty right for for
my scale you could use 1 to 25
that's fine as well but i'll use 1 to
50.
like that
and now my
this particular drawing this drawing
right here is at 1 to 50 scale
right
i will close my properties tab
escape to unselect and from now on i
will not be messing messing around with
this particular layout i can still move
it around and whatnot
right but i will not be
messing around with it
now
here
if if i were to
[Music]
if i were to check
ada05
requirements
stamp
each page will have ada05 stamp
including the name of the student the
date the name of the drawing and the
scale of the drawing on bottom right
side of the page
okay
bottom right side of the page we need a
stamp so what i'm going to do is i will
create a
do we create one more layer
yeah let's create one more layer
and i'll call it
layout
text
layout text
and i'll make it just white color by the
way there are two white colors uh this
one right here which is two five five
it's gonna say two five five here and
there's this one here that's gonna say
white
this one the two five five one is going
to be printed out
white
this one
the one that says white will be printed
out black
okay
rewind if you need it if you need to and
then listen to this again
i'll just hit okay
so we're using the white that's going to
be printed out as black
escape
and i'll just choose this layout text as
my current layer uh current current
layer in which i draw and i'll i'll kind
of start going to town
on this so the first thing that i want
is a bracket
like a a framing of the page so i'm just
going to first draw out an a3 page
um
[Music]
well that's not zero zero zero
coordinates that's weird why well
whatever doesn't matter i'll just draw
out an a3 page
um and it's drawn at one to one scale by
the way so it's 420 millimeters by 297
millimeters by 420
by 297
right like that i'll just move it kind
of close
close to the bottom left corner like so
so that it
it fits with the
page that we have here doesn't need to
be perfect that's fine and now i will
offset
uh this this line here by
uh
10 millimeters yes that's gonna be one
centimeter that's enough
by one centimeter so now i have the
inner bracket and i don't need the old
one uh of
like th this gap is always one
centimeter from the side of the page and
i can use it uh for placing of my
of my stamp
so the stamp is basically just a bunch
of information about the the project
about the drawing and i'm going to be
quite quick about this because there's
nothing smart right so i'm still in the
layout text and i'm going to write write
some text actually right so i'm going to
start writing here
maybe that's a little bit too fast
t enter short for text specify first
corner specify second corner
uh probably change the height of it from
200 millimeters to something a little
bit less
um
so things that are uh less than three
millimeters depending on the font are
becoming harder and harder to read so
i'm gonna say three millimeters
why is this not updating
dd
you are user are not updating at all
that's that is strange
okay
let me try again
select this text
and i double click you now i can't
yes i
uh can we change you
three millimeters
the effect of using the style you know
just
okay this is being um no
this is being a little bit awkward
m text
this is a little bit too big isn't it
but for some reason it oh it
well there's some
[Music]
some issues here and there with the
without account i guess so now it works
let me just uh just to make sure that
this will work as well
let me try
now it says 200
i change this to three
draws as three
either way um either way
let's do this again and now let's do
this
cleanly i guess text
text specify start point of text let's
see from here specify height
so i will specify
um
[Music]
five millimeters in height
specify rotation angle zero
okay it just works
sure uh
my name is
okay
uh next text
t enter
first corner
and i will here i'll just say
[Music]
and here it's
doing another thing
whatever name
that's that's going to be where my name
is going to be
now let's do
the date the name of the drawing and the
scale of the drawing okay so i i still
need some things and honestly once i
have one text object i just kind of like
to make copies of it and just
like double click on it and write what i
need to write so
ad05 we will have
the date
and i know this is not the
20210202
i know that this is not the cleanest way
of how to do it but
whatever works for you there's there's
no rule in how you need to draw it
um
and then there's to be
title and yeah whatever
title
[Music]
and date
okay so now let let's uh make some
some adjustments right uh we need to put
all of this information into into this
corner right here in a kind of
nice nice way so i'm going to draw with
a polyline i'm just going to draw out a
table that is let's say going to be 200
mil
long and that's not horizontal f8
200 millimeters by
um let's say
by by
40
millimeters
by 200
close it off if we need to we'll we'll
trim away some some stuff from it
um and then i'm actually i'm going to
just select this and explode it
so that i can work with each individual
edge
separately or each individual line
separately and i will say that aada05
is going to be located right here
somewhere here
and it actually is going to be scaled
it's going to be twice the size to all
other
um
all other information so i'm just
scaling it to
by two
position it
there we go make a copy of it or make a
copy of this
uh probably some something like so
move this my name is gonna go here
um
you can just kind of position it like so
like that
and now i'm just going to kind of build
a table uh build a table around it
that
that that looks okay
i will center this as well
okay
uh now for the date and the title uh the
title will go in here so i'm just going
to move the title here and i'm going to
kind of double click on it and change
this
it's ground floor plan so it's going to
be ground
floor
plan
m
or scale
1 2
15.
now we can say at 1 250.
usually add is at what height are you
cutting but here we don't really care so
we'll just say 1 to 50.
so that's ground floor plan and then we
have the date
2021
and position it properly that's it uh
that that's all you need to do uh right
so you have your um
[Music]
your stamp here right um
the stamp is it does have much more
information in it but this is just like
first practice
okay so that is done we have our plan we
have our layout everything is correct
let's do two more layouts right so the
way we will do other two layouts is now
by right clicking and choosing to
move or copy
so we right click our existing layout
zero zero plan move our copy
and we choose
move to end
create copy right so there's going to be
a copy created at the end of the layout
line i hit ok
so we have this one
we will right click it and choose to
we will choose to rename it
to
0 1 dash
section
right zero one dash section
uh that is done and then i'm gonna while
i'm at it i'm just going to right click
move an or copy
move to end create copy okay
uh rename rename rename to
zero two
axle
right so we have section xo and plan and
now layout one is just
randomly there so i'm just going to
delete it
no need for that
there we go the only layouts that we
need are these three
okay so we have that uh now for the
section i will double click inside of
this this window uh find the section
zoom into it
zs enter
or
that's
that is not
uh an autocad command that is rhino
command z enter
o
enter there we go that is
autocad command double click out
select the frame
uh pr for properties
annotation scale no not annotation
custom scale uh
that standard scale 1 250
like that
close it off that's done
and i will just change this as well
so
this is section
a dash a at 1 250
that's all we need to change here and
that is done and now axo
double click inside find the axle
zoom selected
z enter oh enter not zoom selected
and this guy right here we don't really
have a scale for it so this is just
going to be axon
axon metric
diagram
something like that
and actually if you want to by the way
if you want to
resize your
uh your window you can you can just
click on these uh
do that these you you select the frame
you click on this
corner point here and you can just
resize it any way you want right
that that that works as well uh axo
doesn't have a scale so i will not be
messing around with it too much
i'll just keep it as it is okay so we
have that done we have axonometric
diagram we have section
we have plan
okay i think we're good so now in the
model space
um
we actually need to
or rather not in the model space let's
go back to layout space
let's change the colors
i i think that's that's important to to
to kind of change the colors
before we do that of course we need to
add the hatches i forgot that i have
deleted the hatch
so let me re-add it real fast
u u u u
u and u enter select the hatch
uh
angled angle is going to be 0 and scale
is 20 that's perfect that's it okay
let's go back to the plan so that's how
it looks like right now
and to change the colors you change the
layer properties right you change the
the properties of the layers
um
for the colors
so
hatch
let's start with the hatch right it's
going to be the easiest one or rather
let's let's leave the hatch for the last
one
um rather let's start with the thick
line the red line right so here
um
well when i am in the model space and i
look at layer properties i can only see
one color right it's it's just
magenta red yellow blah blah blah one
line time one line weight
if i go to my plan
right here
to my layout and i go to layer
properties i can see two colors
that is important
because this is the color of the model
space this is the color
in which it's going to be plotted out or
exported
very big difference
so i am going to in the
um
is it called white space no it's it's
something else um
in this column
sorry sorry about that um in this column
i'm going to change start changing the
colors first right so the thick
thick
line
uh i'll change from the red color to
black
right here or
to white actually
i know it's it's it's confusing but
you'll get used to it so i'll change it
to this white color not this white color
this is this white is going to be
printed out as white this white is going
to be printed out as black right so it
needs to say white here i'll change it
to white
and now if
i
doesn't
go
[Music]
wait a minute
yep that was that was my bad sorry i
figured it out so apparently in the
paper space right here
um
this is what's called the paper space
you can't really override um the the
color this way
so i'll turn this back to red
sorry about that that's a little bit of
a hiccup
uh instead
instead i need to go into the
model space so i need to double click
to go into this view
and here i can go to then i can go to
layer properties just make sure that you
don't accidentally scroll your mouse
wheel or anything like that you don't
mess up the scale
i mean if you mess up the skill you can
always kind of repeat the steps and get
the scale back
either way
once i am inside of this view
that this is super important once i'm
inside of this view then i can override
the color how it's going to be printed
out so thick line is going to be
white
see it turns
uh it turns to black
text is going to be
let's see text is going to be blue in my
case or maybe red yeah let's go for red
oh i'll say text is red
sure
no print is whatever a medium line is
going to be also black so white
i need
i need naming conventions for this uh
thin line
white
and hatch
for hatch i will say
[Music]
dark red something like color
color 14
something like that
right
so i have this
once i've done that i will just escape
out double click outside of the model
space and now i can see the the colors
have changed and
i will just need to do this for every
every layout here
um
a trick on how to do it for all of them
would be just to go into model space
and change every
like in the layer properties come on in
the layer properties change the colors
here and then it will update for all of
the
layouts but sometimes in different
layouts you want different colors um
so so this is
a little bit better to do so double
click inside layer properties and i will
just really quickly go through this so
that was 14
that is gonna be white
it's gonna be white
i wonder if there's like a fast way of
how to do this
like setting everything to white
oh the text needs to be red sorry
like that
double click
and for axo
uh for instance in the axo i don't want
the hatch to be
uh to to be
dark red color i just want it to be like
gray
so here i can change i can change up the
overrides
just make sure that you have double
clicked
layer properties
hatch i will just say
darkish gray
like that
medium line
i'll just go for
black
decline
black
thin line
uh
black text
red
okay something like that
and now you can see
here the hatch is shown in in a
different way right from from all other
layouts
so that is my
that's my initial setup and that is uh
basically what what what i'm dealing
with right now
um
right so we can go to model space and
let's see what other things do we need
to add here right what kind of other
things do do we want to add
for this particular project so
let's see how we can import stuff right
let's see how we can import
objects into our scene such as a person
a tree maybe maybe a tree for the axo
i don't know
maybe nothing for the plan
um so importing
if we go to
pimp my
drawing dot com
at the link is right here
to the linework library
this link right here
if we go here
we can find the person
which which we can use so i will just
kind of use a random
why are there
and that's fine that's a good one
everyone's kind of posing i don't want
them to be posing
i'll just get this guy
so
here we have this person and i can click
on download dwg
and it just kind of downloads it right
and downloads the dwg file so i'll show
in folder
um
that's uh that's the dwg file and all i
need to do is just click and drag
dragon into autocad
release
and click
and then just hit enter enter
enter right for for all of the questions
basically now i have it in autocad right
that is super simple
super simple to do
and it is what's called the block
right so um you can see that all of this
selects at the same time and i perhaps i
don't want it because this is a little
bit too much detail for my type of
project so i will
um and on sorry one more thing before we
kind of look into what a block is it
also imports
with more
layers
or i guess it doesn't
oh it does it just lagged
if if the layers lag just switch between
all and all used right and it's going to
update
autocad come on
um so it does import with these two
layers in our outer which we can just
change like any other layer right in in
the layout
um so that's that's good so for this
person right here i will
uh
look at the uh
for this
import right here i will type in
properties
and i can see that it's imported into
the hash layer but that's whatever but
it's basically well it doesn't say here
oh yeah it does block reference right so
this is a block i don't want it as a
block so how do you get rid of it i want
to use the lines separately how do you
get rid of it
from from being a block you just
exploded
so you selected you exploded and now you
have all of the lines separated right so
i only want the outline of this dude so
i'll take the outline
and i'll just move it
from let's see the bottom of the the
shoe
to somewhere
[Music]
i don't know
maybe near the window
maybe somewhere here
maybe here
yeah somewhere here
so i'll just please place him here right
and then i can just use him to trim
trim away the necessary bits
you know which
he's standing in front of
that
like that okay that's it i have my
silhouette of a person and i don't need
all of the other lines so i'll just
delete them right so honestly then i can
see that it's only the outer layer that
i'm i'm still using the inner layer
which had all of the lines inside of the
person i am not using that anymore so
i'll just delete it
delete the layer altogether
selected layer was not deleted
i will not be deleting it i will keep it
forever
just don't worry about it
anyway for the outer layer
i don't care the color in which it's
shown here but i do care the color in
which it's shown in the layout
especially in the section layout right
here
because right now it's purple
right
so i'll go i'll double click inside of
that layout click layer properties and
change the color to
[Music]
index color choose index color here and
then to white
close that's it double click out we're
good to go
so that's that's the
the person
let me do this again
with the trees
so i will just go to pimpmydrawing.com
uh here in the bottom i'll choose trees
i'll find a nice little let's see this
guy right here
download it as dwg that's a small maple
tree that's perfect in autocad i'll make
sure that i'm in my model space
where is my maple tree five
it's still being downloaded
why is this so slow
123 kilobytes
pause
okay it's it's downloaded actually um so
i'll just drag it in
bam
i'll just place it like so enter enter
enter so i have my small little maple
tree maybe i'll scale it up
um
from this point 1.25
just 125 so that is a little bit larger
than the
then the building
and i will move it down
so i think that's that that that looks
fine
um
perhaps i want it on the other side as
well so i'll just make a copy of it i'll
keep it as a blog by the way in in this
case because i don't really
well
in in case where the maple tree kind of
goes behind the building i would need to
explode it and trim it away
but in other cases i don't maybe i will
just to show you
explode
i explode the block
trim enter enter and i just trim away
the oh
that's gonna be super laggy my mouse is
frozen
okay um so
trimming huh let me turn off the hatch
maybe that's gonna help
uh make zero my active layer turn off
the hatch
i tried trimming again
why is it
why is it lagging
i wonder
shouldn't lag
maybe that's because there's too much
too many lines
if it lags for you as well this this
hard just don't trim the trees
right just don't don't have them trimmed
um
i'll go make some coffee while while
this is
crashing and then we will continue
yep so it completely crashed
which actually
i will use as
an opportunity to show you how to
uh if you have a crash uh what can you
do about it right so
when you load autocad again it's going
to say that in your previous work
session
the program terminated unexpectedly blah
blah
and you can get a backup from your
drawing recovery manager
cool let's see how much it saved so i'll
just hit close
right here and i'll here on the left
hand side of the screen i can see my
backup file and i can see my
[Music]
uh that is not good
that is not good at all
let's see this one
let's see this guy right here so as as
you're clicking through it you can see
like these three versions and
aad05 that the weird one
uh kind of looks like there is a guy
there
so at least that
has been saved so i'm just going to
double click on that
and open it up
and that seems to be okay um at least it
does have
the
the stuff
like that most of the stuff that i have
done so
we're not missing too much and let me
change the camera exposure uh we're not
missing too much so uh i will just
really quickly
um
re recreate what i have been doing and
this time around i will not be trimming
the trees that's for sure so
explode that
so that get the outline move it
m
from here to
wherever it was
over here
fine
enter enter
wonder what's up with the trees and then
then crashing it never used to crash
before maybe the new version really
doesn't like the amount of points that
the three pole lines have
uh that's probably the the culprit
behind it
uh so just keep an eye out for that
either way this is fine and now we just
go to section and we change the
the color of the outer line here
to
white
there we go
um like that
oops
go back to model and just to be sure i
will save
keep saving
so i'll just save it
as aad05
new
hit save
there we go okay so oh yeah and we don't
need those
so the trees
three trees trees again drag dragging
them in placing them
uh one
enter enter enter
scale
from here 1.25
just a little bit bigger just move it
slightly down so that it's kind of
positioned correctly copy it to the
other side
my god
why that's fine um it is what it is so
we have our trees here and i'll actually
copy
um
f8
just have a proper copy here i'll say
that one tree is located here while the
other one is kind of located somewhere
here
maybe this one is
actually here and it's actually
a little bit bigger than the other one
1.25 again
like that so let's look at it in this
section so in the section i can see that
the trees are being blocked off by the
frame a little bit so i'm going to
move the frame
like that
and like that
just so that they are being shown
and also i will change the inner
uh
inner areas of the trees to have a
different color so i'll go to oops
i first need to double click
inside i'll go to layer properties and
here i will just change the inner
layer
color to
the
medium gray
hit okay
close
that's good
same thing for axo
oh for axle we actually need
maybe we'll need to have a smaller axle
that's fine i will just double click and
scale out
super vertical though
click here
and we make this bigger let me just snap
it to the
to the sides here like that
uh that is almost good enough but i kind
of want to move this tree up because i
am dealing with the horizontal
orientation of this so i will go or
rather we can kind of
select all of this
z enter o enter
zoom objects
we can't
maybe we can do it other way around if i
just go to properties
pr and here
uh properties of the
what the hell
that's the polyline oh that's the frame
that's the frame um
i don't want to select the frame though
so how do we do this we can select both
of them
and then from both of them i will just
choose viewport
and here i will just change the the
scale
um let's use custom and if i make this
uh
this number
larger
the scale should increase so
looks like that
let's do
0.0017 or something like that oops
0.017
there we go that's that's fine we can
now
um
clip around here
like so
well that that was the incorrect line
that is fine
kinda still
still work with this
move this in
like so
grab the
line segment here snap it no we can't
snap it
and grab that one then and snap it now
it's fine okay so it was just a little
bit of cleaning up there's there's
nothing nothing special about what i've
what i've done uh there is a little bit
of a tree that's uh kind of sticking
into the
the stamp but that's fine that's uh
that's okay if it if it's doing that
um layer properties let me change the
colors not for the hatch
wait why is oh right right right right
right i need to double click inside and
then change the layer properties to
inner line being medium gray
and the outer line being
black or
it says white but it's black
okay cool we're done
good so that's how you import stuff and
apparently you can't trim
but that's that's good to know oh i
messed it up
so i accidentally zoomed out and now
it's all messy so i will need to
kind of select all of this
zoom enter oh enter again
double click out select the frame
pr for properties and just make sure
that the standard scale is set to 1 to
50.
there we go
so every time when you accidentally zoom
out you need to do this
exo is fine section is fine plan is fine
okay model space
um we have imported stuff we have
that
let's add grid lines
let's add dashed lines
and let's add
measurements
right so the first thing that i'm going
to do is i will add grid lines to
both the plan and
the section and the way you do it is
well first i'll just work with the
helper line
and i'll just draw them out
so the grid lines are usually
anchored to the inner
inner walls
inner side of the walls that's going to
be one grid line that is going to be
another one
that is going to be the third one
[Music]
right here
uh probably
here is going to be the fourth one
fifth one
this one these are used for construction
purposes and they're quite uh quite
quite useful for that uh honestly
i'm thinking of adding a grid line here
as well
i really want to add the grid line for
this but maybe that's not necessary
um
sorry i'm i'm just thinking uh re real
quick i'm just thinking how much we
should add um
let's stick to to these grid lines for
for this particular example then i'm
going to create a rectangle
um and my rectangle is going to be like
so so i'm just kind of drawing around
the
the building
right uh and i'm going to extend so i'll
select the rectangle i'll extend
these lines
to that rectangle so that they penetrate
through the building completely
like that
and also i will trim
the lines that are extending away from
the rectangle
like that once i've done that i just can
delete the rectangle all together so
that's my that's my grid lines and they
will have
some sort of a markup at the at the end
where i can then kind of say what kind
of grid lines i'm using so i will just
use a
let's just do a polyline and let's just
say the length is
a mirror now a mirror is too much
500 millimeters uh by
tens too
too little 50.
sure 500 by 50.
it's kind of a stylized ending for the
for the grid line and from the smith
point i will just kind of move it to the
first grid line here and i'll kind of
copy it to all other positions
like that
take both of these
copy them
to the other side
uh like so and same thing for the
vertical ones i'll just borrow this
like so i will rotate it
or not rotate
around this point vertical there we go
um move to the first one from midpoint
to end point here
copy
copy
enter
and there we go we just kind of go to
town
with them
like that
copy
from the top midpoint to the bottom end
point of the grid lines
let's make sure that everything fits in
the plan everything does fit in the plan
that's great let's go back here um so
that's our our gridlines they do need
markups uh basically
naming for for the gridlines so i will
borrow this text
yeah this this
section markup text i'll just copy it
near the first horizontal grid line
something like so
let's go for below it right and actually
that text here can be smaller so i'll
just scale it
scale it down by 0.5
to a pretty small text let's just double
check how it looks like it's pretty
small but that's fine
and it's basically going to be
horizontally i'm going to have grid line
a and b and vertically i'm going to have
1 two three four five right so you
always
distinguish between directions by naming
and the naming is alphabetical in one
direction and in the other one it's
numbers usually use numbers for the
direction which has more grid lines as
well
so i'll just copy
a
a
a
a
and this one i will just change to b
uh the axle doesn't need to have a grid
line
uh to have any grid lines or any
dimensions whatsoever so a grid line b
grid line that's great
same thing for these guys right here
i'll just kind of
take this
copy this
somewhere close by doesn't need to be
perfectly precise i'll just rename this
to one
i'll just kind of make a copy of it
so that's going to be one
that's going to be two
three
four ah
and stuff with the four
copy
four and
five
double click on the text
rename it to two
double click on the text rename it to
three
and the text
four
and the text
five
that's done
now i just need to select these
and copy them down
copy
um
from here to
here
okay
so we have our gridline markups done
the grid lines themselves are still in
the
helper
line layer so i need to fix that i will
or axes i guess we need to call them
axes
sorry
oh wait i'm not sorry it's it's both
grid lines and axis in this case so i
will select just the ends of them and i
will change them to text layer so that
the ends are going to be red and the
axes themselves
i'm going to create a new layer for them
new layer and i'll call it axis
or access
doesn't matter axis and i'll
here for now just change the color of
them to be also well maybe not yellow
maybe let's do orange
right just to distinguish between them
so these are going to be done in orange
for now
in the model space
i just select them
i messed that up
there we go
and we change this to
axis layer there we go so that is done
almost um
if i look at it in the in the plan
layout
uh i can see the
why is this
that's strange it should be red right
it's in the model space it's red
oh sorry yeah the model space is in the
green layer why is it here
still shown as black
just give me a second
layer helper
so it doesn't update
what the hell
that is a bug again
that is super weird uh sure we can
change them here
uh while we are in the model space
in the layout i can force them to be in
the text
layer
i don't know why why that happens and
now i messed it up i messed up the scale
that's fine we just kind of zoom into it
zoom enter z enter o enter zoom into it
double click out
select the
frame properties and change the
scale again to 1 to 50.
it's so super strange that it doesn't
wasn't isn't that reactive uh it didn't
have this kind of bugs in previous
versions uh i assume you will not have
these bugs if you're working with an
older version
anyway um
the lines themselves i want to change
some properties of them so i'll go to or
the axis lines i'll go to layer
properties and here where i see axes
first of all i'll change the color of
them and i'll change the color to
probably
dark red
color
let's just hope that it kind of works oh
[Music]
need to be inside of the model space
their properties here we change the the
the axis layer
color to dark red
there we go
uh so that is done but also
while i'm at it i don't want this to be
a solid line i want this to be a dashed
line so i will mess around with the line
type
right
the
viewport
or yeah viewport line type right so
while i'm still here
uh where i see vp line type i'll click
on this continuous
name here for the wait am i in the
helper no for the axis continuous and
i'll load a line type that i want and in
this case for for these particular uh
lines i want it to be dash
dash dot
long dash dot um that is
used for the axes right so i'll just hit
okay
so now it got imported and we can use
this line type right and i'll just
choose it and
use ok and now i can see that my line
types
have been updated and now they are dash
dotted
[Music]
you can change the line type scale
but i wouldn't suggest doing it if it
works
okay so we have this going on that's
great let's jump into this section
right here and we kind of need to add
the grid lines to the section as well so
i'll go back to the model space
my battery ran out of the camera this is
a long tutorial
[Music]
just give me a second
new
battery please
there we go
should be good
so
section right uh the the way you add uh
gridlines to the section once you have
them in the plan is super simple you
just grab the ones that you already have
made in the correct direction and you
just copy them down
uh perfectly down
like so
that's it that's done
that's done because these are perfectly
aligned right uh you will not be seeing
gridlines a and b
in this section
naturally
um then there's some change and here it
actually updates i don't know
so here we need to change the
display as well of of these grid lines
so i'll go to layer properties well
double click layer properties and here i
will just change from
[Music]
from the axis
color
to be
that dark red color that i wanted
and the line weight or line type vp line
type
i will change
wait
line type there we go vp line type i
will change to dashed okay
um
that is done
and that is it okay
okay okay okay
so
we don't need to do anything with this
this looks fine this looks fine oh yeah
and double click out of it so that you
don't accidentally zoom in
to the drawing
now one last thing
before we plot everything out is adding
dimensions
and i'll start with the plan as per
usual i'll create a new layer
new layer
called them
just kind of
name it them
for dimensions and i will make it
red in this case
or
we are using red color so let me make it
uh
orange we are using pink we are running
out of colors here let's just have white
then that's fine
that's fine so dimensions is going to be
done in
white
color
uh let's find it dim
there we go so dimensions one last thing
right
um
if we go to the annotate tab
here
here we have the settings for our text
for our dimensions and then and whatnot
so there is um
there are presets already so sorry the
dimensions tab is right here right
annotate tab dimension sub tab right
here and there are preset dimensions
that that we can see here
and these are not that not that great
we want to make our own so what i'm
going to click on is this manage
dimension style so again you click on
this drop down box and you choose manage
dimension styles right here
which will give you this uh table
where i can create a new
dimension right and i'm gonna do that
exactly that new
i'll call it
my
pull
them
micro dimension
uh and i'll start with uh whatever
either standard or iso you do not start
with annotative though that is something
else
do not tick mark annotative uh the way
annotative works is uh
as you're zooming out the dimensions
will increase in size so they are kind
of locked in size in terms of
millimeters
uh you don't really want that in this
particular project in larger projects
you do use annotate but
that's going to be layer that's going to
be much much later
um
use for all dimensions yes okay so
do this hit continue
and this is where you kind of set up all
of your all of your dimensions so the
first thing is color color is going to
be
uh by layer
that's important
so all of your dimensions are going to
be colored by the layer in which they
are in
then line type is going to be by layer
and line weight is going to be by layer
so we are controlling the dimensions
through layer
not through block
then you have baseline spacing if i
change this to 500 for instance
nothing happens
whatever then we ignore it
is it that bug again uh we'll see if
it's a bug or not
um
you do have suppression though so
suppression is if if you kind of change
these things you can see what what
changes here so if we suppress them
lines both of them you don't see the
the arrows anymore right so
we don't want that to happen
um
extend beyond them lines uh that is this
is by the way in millimeters so this is
very very small
uh if i change this to 10 you can see
that
these lines get extended uh much further
so here i'm just going to say
and this is where we're going to kind of
start messing it up
um
for now let's keep it at 10. we will
come back to this we will we will indeed
come back to this everywhere where you
see by block you change to by layer
this is just the way you do it by layer
right
um
we will come back to the extension
in just a second also to the offset but
for now i want to change the symbols so
in architecture we don't use arrows we
use
dashes or ticks architectural ticks
right so the arrowheads are
architectural ticks the leader is
architectural deck or the leader can be
a dot as well that that's fine
uh we can use a dot for the arrow size
this is 2.5 millimeters in size that is
way too small because you know this is
like 400 millimeters thickness so we
wanted the
the tick mark to be around 100
millimeters
and now you can see how it messes up the
view that's fine we will fix it
uh center marks um
that we we will not be working with
center marks that's fine
uh arc length symbol we don't care about
anything else here
yeah so it's just these these four
things here uh then for the text we will
change the text height so the text
height right now is again oh by the way
text color by layer
right
um
text height we will change this to
higher uh text of course
and we will use something around
um i want to say 75 millimeters
i'll just do 75 and now we can see that
we are back back in business right so so
it's it's kind of
um
back to what it was uh before text
placement um i do want to offset it from
so it needs to be above the
uh and centered to the dimension line uh
but i do want it to be offsetted above
it a little bit more so i'll just give
it like if the text size is 75 uh let's
just offset it by 25. so it's kind of it
has a gap here um text alignment aligned
with dimension line perfect that's
that's fine nothing else nothing else
here fit
for the fit
over the only thing that i change is
text placement if it doesn't fit uh in
the dimensions it needs to be over the
dimension line with a leader
um it's basically if if
text doesn't fit here then it's going to
kind of draw this this line here
um
like an angled line and it will show a
text somewhere else
um then here you can see that it's like
full num it's not full numbers it's with
a comma and we are dealing with
millimeters so we don't uh we don't do
this
we need to kind of show only full
numbers
uh so under primary units where it says
precision i will change the precision to
zero
so it only gives us full numbers
okay so we have that done tolerances we
don't care about alternative units we
don't care about do we care about
anything else here
no no we don't okay back to lines tab
um under extended dumb lines i had it as
10 so 10 now is super small i will have
it as hundred
so the ticks extend
the dimensionless extent by a hundred
all right i think that's it i think that
is it that's all we need to do
let me double check yeah everything
seems fine i'll just hit ok
uh my cool dimension is now my
new created dimensional style i'll click
close i'll make sure that it's my active
dimensional style here and now i can
start adding dimensions
so
in the top
and on the side
here
i want to add dimensions
and also i kind of want to anchor the
dimensions to somewhere maybe the corner
here or maybe that this intersection
between one and a is going to be my
anchoring point
that's fine um
so these guys will have dimensions
anchored to the
axes
while on this side i can just kind of
add some some additional dimensions here
and there that that i want to
uh that i want to showcase maybe i won't
maybe just for the windows
um
let's do it so
my cooldim is my active dimension and
here i have two options for the
dimension styles well there's actually
more options here because if you want an
aligned dimension you can have that as
well
i will show you all of them or at least
three of them
so linear dimension is basically if i
click on it
and i click on first point click on the
second point
drag it out
you know that that's that is a linear
linear dimension so the thing about
linear dimension is that it can only go
either horizontally or vertically
right it can't go at an angle if i want
it at an angle i need to use what's
called an aligned dimension where is it
where is it
where is it
ah there it is okay so uh
we click on the small icon right next to
linear dimension expand it and we can
see aligned dimension here if i select
aligned and i click click then it
creates this
angled dimension right so
for this particular building we won't
need any aligned dimensions just know
that you can have those
i will just be using linear
linear
from here to here
and
if you want to have
if you don't want to kind of keep
repeating the dimension command you can
use uh continue
this
pool right here which basically just
will continue on from the last dimension
that you've done
and you can just kind of then only click
once and once you're done you just hit
enter
and it's going to add the dimensions
right so then i'm usually the way i do
it is i create a single linear dimension
and then if i want to continue from it i
just click on continue and then do it
that way
now for the
uh
for some additional anchoring i will do
i will do a linear dimension between the
corner of the building to the axis one
that is going to be 400 millimeters then
i'll continue it until the start of the
um of the window
generally here and then i'll kind of
continue it
all the way through
to the end of the building like so
so now i have registered these two
corner points here and also the position
of the window according to those two
corner points and i'll do the same thing
here a single linear dimension from here
to here
or sorry my bad
first of all from here to here
then continue it until here
here
and actually just until here we don't
need to anchor it to to here or do we
well maybe we can why not
so that's done
that is done if we look at it in the
plan view
that is how it looks like
and again in the plan view it's not
showing oh yeah that's fine it doesn't
need to show up
as
as red for now but i will double click
inside
i will go to the layer properties tab
and for dimensions i will change their
color to red
like that
okay so that's done that is done
now
for the
section so for this section you
typically you do have dimensions here
but since this is such a small project i
will not be adding them but you what you
do have is you have elevations right uh
you mark out
different
uh altitudes for for different things so
we won't have a lot of elevations here
we will have one here
um i'll i'll just kind of draw lines
here
um there's gonna be an elevation here
um
and i want an elevation here but that
doesn't really matter
and an elevation here
well yeah and uh elevation showing
what's what's zero what what do we
consider to be
considered to be zero right
so
these are the elevations that i want to
mark out and for that i first need a
markup of the elevations so there are
different styles of markups uh the one
that i like using is this so we start
drawing from the horizontal line and
i'll just do like 500 mil
uh that's too too large let's do
250 millimeters like so so we just have
like this horizontal line that's uh 250
millimeters then i'm gonna draw down
by
uh
let's say
50 millimeters
like that this is going to be my helper
line and this is enough for me to kind
of
this amount of lines is enough for me to
draw out my markup so let me do it real
fast online tool from this
left hand side point to the end to the
bottom
then we move across up
like that and we extend it like so
right so this is you can treat this fall
line basically as an arrow
showing like looking downwards right and
then i'm just gonna borrow a number
here
since i already have it
move
like that
and i'm just going to kind of change the
the layer of the number to
dimensions double click on it and change
change it to plus
x point x xx
or three x's right
uh that is how
altitudes are written while dimensions
are written in millimeters altitudes are
always written in meters with three
digits after the comma this is how you
distinguish between what's an altitude
and what's an elevation
or what's a dimension writer
so let me copy this
from this point i will want to show this
point here i want to show this point
here i will want to show this point here
and you can see the graphical uh
problems that we will have i will fix
them
i will want to show this point here
uh point on the ground
and this point right here right so let's
get rid of the helper lines now
like that that that
no no need for that that
that and that oh and that
and now let's start
kind of cleaning everything up so this
guy right here uh intersects with the
building so we don't want that i will
just move it to the side and i will
create one more line segment
that kind of does its thing like so
and for this one the same thing but
in this case it doesn't need to extend
too much a little bit more
like that
line
segment drag it out like so
everything else is okay um everything
else is not in the way so now let's add
the numbers right so always the floor
plate like the top of the floor is 0.000
so it's neither plus nor minus it's
actually plus minus
right so i will
how do you
[Music]
i forgot how to insert a special
character oh no
well if if you don't uh
if you can't use a special character you
can always do this plus minus
that works as well 0.000
right that is our
starting elevation and that is our floor
plate then i know that this is
let me just actually i don't let me
measure the distance
this is
1.1 meters above the floor plate right
so this is going to be plus
1.100
right
that's that's the altitude and this one
is going to be again measured distance
from here to here
2750
so it's going to be plus 2 pounds two
point seven five zero
then here we will have probably
i'll just measure this seven hundred
so three four five zero
three four
feels weird wait is it really three four
five zero
uh yes it is okay
and then this height right here
distance
from let's see this line to
here
two three zero zero
plus two point three
zero zero
and the last one here it's going to be
i remember i just moved it by five
centimeters down so it's going to be
negative right
minus 0.050
that's it that's that's all of the
all of the elevations let's look at them
in this section that's how they look
like in this section and i want to
change their their colors in the section
as well so i'll
go to layer properties double click
don't forget to double click go to layer
properties dimension
and here just change it to whatever
color we're using we are using red
color for these markups double click out
we're good to go
okay so we have our plan we have our
section and all of them have
dimensions
okay last thing
last thing to do
is to actually plot this out right to
create a pdf
or actually let me
i'm now scared that i'm rushing and i
will forget something important so
let me just
double check
match properties okay that's that's one
that that we can that i can show you as
well uh one last
trick i guess if you have let's say
a line here right
come on align
right and it's in dimensions layer and
you want to change its layer you can
match
match properties m a
shortcut for it is m a and then you
choose source object so let's see this
guy right here
right and then you just click on the
object to which you want to match the
properties to
like that and it's going to
move it in the same layer as the source
and change its all of the properties to
be the same of the source usually it's
used for hatches
if i have
[Music]
if i have a hatch
you know something like this and i want
to make it exactly the same as this i
can match properties
m a enter from this hatch to this hedge
right so it just kind of
matches these two hatches together quite
useful quite a useful little tool
um
no we are not still plotting it out i
haven't told you about the
i haven't done one last
thing
which is adding dashed lines
here we won't have any dashed lines will
we
almost nothing is above
but here here we will have a dashed line
because there's a like a cupboard above
and that cupboard is going to be
a little bit thinner than the
than the
block here
so i'm going to
create a new layer and i'll
change to
dashed
so this layer will have all of the
dashed lines i'll change the dashed
lines color to also yellow let's let's
go for yellow that's fine and
in the line type i will change actually
i will change it here in the line type i
will change it to
load it and i'll change it to just iso
dash okay
choose it okay and now we have a dash
layer that's yellow and that has a line
type of the dash right
the dash
um
so now in that layer
next layer i'll just create a polyline
here
that's going to go all the way to here
and we'll
actually we can kind of do this
that would look pretty cool
now let's stick to it um
350 let's see
like that
that
so this is basically a cupboard above
and you can see it's it's dashed but the
dash is very very thin uh let's see if
it's actually so thin in the plan here
and it's not right that's because well
you don't really see it do it's super
yellow so let me change the
color of it to black
there we go
so it is dashed here right
oh
i stood up
by the way if if you can't zoom out or
click out of the model space as you're
in the viewport
you can always click here where it says
model you can click
click on it and then you are going to be
in the paper space right so you don't
necessarily need to click out so let me
fix this again
one
z enter oh enter
double click out uh select this
properties
keep messing it up i just keep messing
it up one two fifty
what's that that's done okay
so now that's that's a dashed line right
there
last thing
thicknesses
right everything right now is the same
thickness
we don't want that we want the
thicknesses to be different and i will
use global values rather than local
values for thicknesses so i'll do that
in the model space rather than
individually i or separately in every
layout so i'll go to the layer
properties
tab here and
thicknesses are controlled through line
weights
so
the thinnest line that you can have
which still
prints out by most of the
plotters
is 0.09 millimeters
anything
thinner than that
uh some older printers will have
problems with it and by older i mean
printers that are used a lot
uh so in the school for instance
um
[Music]
anything lower than 0.09 will not print
out that well
when i see 0.09 i mean 0.09 millimeters
so those will not print out that well
uh so instead
uh we are going to lock our smallest
distance or smallest thickness of the
line to 0.09
um and then everything
the size that we will kind of keep
increasing in in thickness
in regards to that
there's something else that i wanted to
mention
all right if you're printing with white
lines
above
uh black background so white on black
then your thickness of the lines needs
to be a little bit thicker
because
there is a little bit of color bleed
right off of the black color so
if if your lines are too thin they will
get eaten up so if you're printing with
white on black i would suggest
smallest
line thickness to be 0.12
millimeters rather than 0.09
so here with the line weights let's
let's go to town with them so axes axes
are usually
very thin so i'll use 0.09 on them
dashed line is also a thin one i'll use
0.09
definition points i have no idea what
those are we ignore them
dimension
dimension lines are usually a little bit
thicker
so i'll use 0.13
hatch
depends on your style but i prefer using
very thin lines 0.09
helper we are not using helper layer
we're not printing with the helper layer
so we don't care
inner
that's inner lines for the
trees
those can be super thin
[Music]
0.09
then we have layout text
that can be
a little bit thicker 0.15
medium line thickness needs to be
thicker than all of these
so i'll choose 0.2
no print that's important remember we
created the no print layer
that one shouldn't be printed so we
control it through the line weights we
scroll down
we don't scroll down we scroll up and we
see 0.00
right that's the no print
basically lines that don't have any
thickness
so no print will have 0.00
outer line
for these things will probably be medium
so like the same as medium so i will use
0.2
uh text
uh text can be
somewhere in between
something close to dimensions so
dimensions are 0.13 so let's use that
0.13 for the text
thick lines
i will go for 0.4
so double the thickness of the outer
lines and thin lines are of course 10
0.09
um
yeah let's see
let's take a let's take a look uh you
can't really see it here
we need to start uh plotting it out for
you to actually
for you to actually see it right
um so let's plot everything out
uh shortcut for plotting stuff out or
exporting pdfs is p
no
i lie it's not p
just write plot
i guess
plot enter
[Music]
um
it will ask you for this we noticed that
you have multiple drawings
um it's available for plotting multiple
sheets at once what do you want to do so
you can either plot out
all of them at once
or you can plot them out one by one
for this particular purpose i will be
plotting them out one by one just so
that i can show you how you can combine
them with the
online tools into one pdf right so
i will say continue to plot a single
sheet right but you can use
try batch plot
you can use that as well so i'll
continue
it's going to kind of give me this plot
settings again and i can actually click
on preview here
to see how it's going to look like
produced by autodesk student version
great
um
so yeah that's that's education version
right there uh so we are going to be
plotting out this
right
um i i just click the close button i hit
okay
and i'll just plot it to my desktop let
me just create a new folder here i'll
just call it plot raw
plot raw
why are you crashing again
[Music]
location is not available it is it's
right here
oh my god
um
pdf document sure i'll call it uh we're
plotting out the plan so i'll just call
it plan
hit save
and it's done uh and i can kind of take
a look at it
right here desktop plot raw
plan
double click that
for some reason to rotate it that's
whatever that why is it rotated
you shouldn't be rotated
don't be weird
let's see
it's lansky format
that's fine
what if i use a different
lighting technique adobe pdf
and i plot it this way
i'm just kind of checking what what
works more stable at this point
so i'll overwrite it and i need to close
this to be able to override it
let's see if adobe pdf will will do as
good
definitely slower definitely slower
come on you can do it it's not a big
project
oh my god man oh there we go it's also
rotated okay so that's weird but that's
fine uh we can have it rotated that's
okay
um
so we have that
then let's do the section by the way
shortcut even
faster shortcut is ctrl p
uh continue
plot
i'll just use the regular one hit ok
uh that's section
save
and then for axo ctrl p
plot
a3
okay
exo
save
and of course you will have a
you will have more you will have the
title page as well but
not i'm
i'm curious to see what you'll come up
with so
i will not be showing you the title page
uh let me just save this file just just
in case it crashes again
um so we have these three
we have the plan
right here we have the axo
right here
and we have the
section which i mispronounced right here
right everything seems to be in order
even though it's it's a little bit messy
then what you can do honestly like
i shouldn't probably be showing you this
but what you can do is you can open them
up in photoshop
let me just quickly
really quickly
show you how to kind of connect this to
the previous
previous course that we had
so let's open up photoshop
um
[Music]
i'll just take all three of these
drag and drop them in
as copies
and i will
as as i have drawn
dropped them in it's going to ask me for
how do i want to import this very
important to have media box
set
as cropping
rather than bounding box that's very
important everything else is whatever
hit okay
then here media box okay
and here media box okay so we have now
them opened up in photoshop which means
that here i can mess around with them i
can go to image image rotation
counterclockwise
image image oops that's kind of a size
that's bad image image rotation
counterclockwise
image
image rotation counterclockwise so i
have them like rotated back to to normal
orientation and i also can add like
create a new layer drag it below the
existing layer uh grab the white color
shift f5 to fill
and and basically just create white
background that way i'm going to do the
the same thing for for all of them
like that
like that and also i can while i'm at it
i can come in here and i can kind of
select the autodesk
student version then you can just
no no no this was done with a
professional version right don't
no no no it's it's a normal professional
version oops
uh ctrl d
or ctrl z
ctrl z
there we go
uh this one will need a little bit more
precision
and up
believe that
a little bit of crap is left there but
the teacher will not notice trust me
delete that
delete that
and the last one delete that okay so
that is cleaned up
while i'm here i can kinda oh you can
still see a little bit of the border no
no no
we delete the border
there we go
so i messed up a little bit there
apparently
that particular plotting technique still
keeps
like a tiny bit of the border that's
fine uh there's also an option for you
to
um
go in here
where is it
going here select this object and i
believe
there needs to be
there needs to be like no print option
here yeah there we go so there's also
like this whole segment here where we
can change
[Music]
the border
the no print layer to be
actually
no print
like so
right if you click on this it's not
going to be printed out
that's something uh to to to know so
it's either changing it to 0.000
millimeters in thickness or not printing
it out altogether apparently
uh
0.000 doesn't always work which is news
to me
it used to work
i feel old
um
oh yeah axel we need to clean up the
axle
delete that
delete that
delete that nope
i am deleting the wrong things
or rather the long wrong layer
there we go there we go
[Music]
there we go
and now
precision
decision there we go
good enough
good enough um
what else can we do with this
i don't really want to do anything more
with this uh you could while you're in
photoshop you could kind of add color
texture or whatnot to it but i don't
really want to do it what i want to do
is
clean this bad boy up
so this is actually
this shows very well the difference
between
vector graphics and raster graphics see
how the
the lines are not infinite in resolution
anymore
uh this is because we're dealing with
them in photoshop
right
and photoshop works with pixels
so these three are now cleaned up i'll
just save them just ctrl s
to save
i choose photoshop pdf i'll go to my
desktop
plot raw and i'll just kind of override
them or let's just do exo
clean
like that i will not be saving the layer
so i'll untick that i'll hit save
hit ok
everything else here is fine
hit save
and same thing here
pdf
plan
clean
no layers
save
section
uh
pdf
section clean
now layer save okay
we are almost there last thing
is combining them so you can either
combine them with
adobe
pdf by just kind of selecting all three
of them
or acrobat reader
selecting all three of them right
clicking on them
and choosing combined files in acrobat
so if you don't have that option
right if you don't have that option then
you
then then then you need to use the
website combine pdfs online which is
also super super neat uh drop your files
here uh exo plan
exo plan section
there we go drag and drop them in
it's uploading
uploading it's done and now i can kind
of arrange them so first i want the plan
then i want the section then i want the
axo and then i just click on combine
and now it's downloaded here
go in folder
my computer is just
not up to par
one
you can do it it's just opening a folder
there we go so we have that and
i'll just add it to
[Music]
to the plot raw for folder sure and i'll
say
aada05
geridekis
get the minus
right
then i will
i can either email it to myself and
use the
use they used to use the
[Music]
how is it called remote student desktop
to login to one of the computers and
open up the email from the the computer
in the school and upload it to the
to the server from there which is a
viable solution and super easy to do or
i can just simply
if if you are a little bit more
technology
focused i guess uh you can just connect
to
the vpn blendvpn and then you will have
access to the servers this is a little
bit harder to do though
but then you just
kind of go to the thumb folder
unprotected
and in
and you just simply
drag and drop in your
your file
that's it you have successfully finished
the course
right
let's look at the file
let's look at the file this is how it
looks like the thicknesses of the lines
are okay they're not not spectacular but
they are fine i would probably if i
needed to
kind of
readjust them i would probably
um
increase the thickness in some cases
let's look at it at a hundred percent i
would increase the thicknesses and then
in in certain cases the hash is fine the
thin lines could be a little bit thicker
though
and the medium line could be a little
bit thicker other than that this is okay
that's the section section is okay
section looks fine
um and the axle looks great
simple minimalist i like it
[Music]
right that is it that is it
hope you
will have fun finishing up the project i
know it's a lot of information in the
last uh
last bit of of these tutorials but that
is all of the information that you need
to produce any kind of project honestly
so
that's great now once once you're done
with the course you are full-fledged
architects
just kidding anyway
go and have fun with the projects
i'll see you next time
[Music]